two
hello everybody and welcome welcome to
the h3 podcast it's wednesday march 16th
[Music]
wow
another masterpiece and you know
it's a reflection of the show we have
planned here today high energy
so much to talk about i oct the music by
the way keep the music going i'll keep
it going by the wonderful
otis mcdonald an incredible talent who
made this beautiful theme song
[Applause]
love it so much
yeah keep the vibes up baby play it the
whole [ __ ] episode
i'm still recovering
from being sick but
my throat doesn't really hurt today but
now i'm congested
congested
so that's what's going on sorry that's
disgusting but
it's doing this
this is sick
today's episode's sponsored by liquid iv
and curology
you guys want me to beg for subscribers
because we drop below
3 million i can do it if you want it's
not going to happen people it's it's
you're not gonna say that well you're
framing it incorrectly you've got to see
that like button guys
we are
less than a thousand away from hitting 3
million it could happen live this day on
the show it could happen let me check
guys this is so exciting
we're gonna finally hit 3 million subs
we are only 300 away guys let's go be
smashing that subscribe button and like
button
smash that like button and like and
subscribe
[Music]
come on baby
i've dreamed of this moment for years to
finally hit 3
million subscribers what an honor to do
it live
with all you guys here what a it's a
dream come true
once in a lifetime
all right well
here we are how's everyone doing
pretty good
i'm doing good i did i'd be really good
if people smash that like button and
turn on notifications and subscribe
i just said that i know but you know i
gotta say it a few times every time
you got to keep going
you guys care more about it than i do
why do you i mean i appreciate it but
you you take it personally i feel like
when it drops below no personally i just
think you know we're the best show on
the internet these little yeah youtube
where the cliche hacks were at least the
14th best show on the internet dan
that was our
ranking on the page
oh well those other ones are they don't
count necessarily because like who who
is uh
you know who beat eddie like shitty
heads just shad heads this is a you this
is an internet show those guys are doing
whatever they talk [ __ ]
right i love fluffy because they're
[ __ ] in the words of love
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude
[Laughter]
my arch nemesis oliver tree was talking
[ __ ] it was concert unbelievable
what is this
[Music]
[Applause]
what is he tearing up
[Applause]
[Music]
okay dude honestly
this is what i said
first of all i ratioed him okay so let
that be known oliver tree's a washed up
has been he has one song that people
like he's a fake cowboy he's only
watched brokeback mountain once by the
way which he confided at me which i'm
outing him now your um your laptop
screen cut out right as you went to go
play that play play the video one more
time we heard the audio
[Music]
[Applause]
pretty epic
[Applause]
[Music]
whatever bro i was like those are all
our fans just humor you we're the only
reason you're actually even selling
tickets
he's got one song he's a washed up
husband he's a fake ass cowboy
every any real cowboys watch brokeback
mountain at least
100 times
at least the good parts he can't ride a
ball he can barely ride a scooter and
his hair sucks and he owes his career to
me and also i ratioed him so
you really did ratio him yeah
double the amount
and then
yeah so whatever oliver loser douche
what the [ __ ]
he just wants to box me
he's gonna have to offer me three
million like keemstar did
would you take him up on that for three
milliliter box oliver tree
i'd box anyone for three million by
keemstar i would i wouldn't box game
stuff for any amount of money because i
don't want to legitimize him
because once you take the money and you
get in the ring with him that everyone
then it turns into like i don't actually
care that he like
had a part in someone unaliving
themselves and and and like ruining
people's lives calling them
right faking that they're a pedo i'm
like no i would have would you box
jeffrey epstein and like a
and well he's dead now
oh yeah
just saying
i'd [ __ ] his i'd [ __ ] his body up
i'm just saying
it's it's in a way a cosign of keemstar
which i i can't yeah you're right i mean
yeah making money or
helping him make money yeah it's a
spectacle yeah right and i'm clouding
him up by doing this fight all right
which
he deserves no clout
no club for me
um
oh this was good tim dylan you know
of all the comedians who are like
adjacent to joe rogan well that's not
true i like a lot of them i like tom
segura and bert and christina p and all
these guys burke rice sure bobby lee
there i don't know if bobby lee's in
joe's orbit i remember he said that i
don't think they get along there's some
beef i believe that's my boy that's why
i love bobby lee because
that's good because he's not he's not
dick riding joe for [ __ ] clown
all these guys are true yeah what's the
beef is it public i think it goes back
to the carlos mencia days of um
him like calling out
joe rogan calling out carlos mencia and
like he was asking bobby lee about it
and he like put out the interview
publicly without
bobby's consent and bobby was like close
with carlos mancia
so that caused some drama
yeah
well that's that's not a great hill to
die on
because carlos vancius was
stealing jokes from people right yeah
barbados
but anyway i stand bobby lee bobby's the
greatest but i was my point was is that
tim is one of the good ones who
uh he's just so funny you know and i've
seen him go on rogan and he challenges
him and he gives him [ __ ] and i liked
him
you know he
sometimes he's on some weird [ __ ] but
for the most part he's funny but he's
with alex jones too yeah but the thing
about tim is that like he just
i don't think he has an affiliation one
way or the other he's just entertaining
you know i think he's just in it for the
lols
but anyway here he's talking about
garyvee there he's like content
content that's how you get out of it
how do you fix ukraine so what you have
is you have this country right now
that's being ripped apart
you're just being [ __ ] up [ __ ]
ripped apart okay do you know what do
you know what it's like to be one day
you're sitting in your bedroom the next
day you're [ __ ] outside of your
bedroom you're not even in it anymore
you're outside of it walking you don't
even know where you're gonna do so what
are you gonna do when you're walking
when you're walking so you're walking
how many times you so from from ukraine
to poland what is that 70 80 100 000
miles whatever it is
how many tick tocks can you make on the
way to the border how many hats that's
okay you would say that you on the way
to the border you can have three
companies by the time you get to poland
you'll be a millionaire in poland it's a
blessing every second
he dude no it's pretty much spotted it's
i'm surprised garyvee hasn't said that
well we don't follow him that closely
maybe he has
how to fix how garyvee will fix ukraine
and that that's just i love that oh
people are saying bobby and joe made up
when was the last time bobby was on
joe's podcast because i remember the
last time i saw him
he's never been
i don't think so dude i don't think he
has i mean i remember him talking about
never being
on it but that was a while ago so is it
joe's never invited him that's pretty
that's pretty trashy he's been invited
oh and then do you think bobby passed
it's just
i think he they just said that it never
happened for bernie sanders
ethan don't be like that
we should get bobby back in here
he's a delight
very funny
yeah so
love that
i'm saying he was on like a long time
ago when like joe rogan before he had
his studio but i think he was going to
skype yeah
okay
um
this sounds good contestant hits her
head and gets knocked out
survivor all-star oh i was watching this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
bro nice help
i don't think she got her head got
caught on the rope or something
[Applause]
he like body slapped her stomach he
definitely knocked the air out of her
what a guy huh what a teammate
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for the help dude speaking of
reality shows sam i'm going to need you
here to talk about this because i
watched bachelor last night
this season of bachelor was the craziest
thing did anyone watch that
uh no but i've been hearing all about it
here comes sam oh my god fam we need you
we need you watch that sam
i know you watched it we talked about it
do you think i would miss that
best season ever right i agree i think
it's one of the best for sure so this
guy clayton
i don't think i i could spoil it you've
seen if you care you've already seen it
if you care spoilers
so
i'm not going to spoil the end so he he
has three finalists and when you get
three finalists you get to do this thing
called the fantasy suite where you get
to spend on overnight with the girls
and
um
basically
have private time all day all night with
no cameras or anything
they don't they don't always have sex
but
they can
so this guy clayton he had three
finalists he told each one of them
separately um he goes i'm falling in
love with you and i'm shouting it from
the top of the world and each one of
these girls is so convinced he's gonna
pick her in the end and he has sex with
each one all three well at least the
first two okay and then the third one
his final date he says to her
um
she goes listen i just want to know have
you told any of the other girls you love
them or have you slept with them because
that'd be a deal breaker for me which
makes sense right the idea is that they
get engaged at the end so how are you
gonna get engaged a guy you just smash
two girls less than 24 hours earlier
that's not the good that's not a good
way to start a relationship and so
you could see he starts sweating bro
he's like oh [ __ ]
and this is the girl he liked the most
which everybody knew
and he's like oh [ __ ] he's like well you
told me to explore all the relationships
so i could know and just pick you
and she's like yeah bro that didn't mean
smashing and telling everyone that
you're in love with them
so she leaves
oh the thing is he tells her no but i
love you the most
he says i love you the most
then the other two so she bails and then
when the other two girls learn that she
left
he's like listen i have to be frank with
you i told both of you that i love you
and that i sl and also i've slept with
both of you
he tells them together and then they
freak out
they're leaving
and then he's bet and then he goes no no
no please stay i'm in love with you my
tr he he begs them both to stay he says
you have to stay i'm in love with you
please stay
he doesn't tell them that i told the
other girl i was in love with her the
most then after he begs the two girls to
stay
and they decide okay i'm gonna stay
because once again he makes them both
feel separately that they're gonna he's
gonna pick them right so after they have
already humiliated themselves and agreed
that they're gonna stay
then he goes
he privately he goes home and he goes yo
i'm in love the one girl that i want is
the one girl that left and i'm have to
break up with them now
and then he brings him out
together
as a group and says i just want to let
you guys know that my heart is elsewhere
and i'm gonna have to sit i'm gonna have
to walk you guys out some [ __ ]
and it's just pure pandemonium he gets
eviscerated bro
um sam did i give a proper recounting of
that that was great i just i can't
believe that he fought for rachel and
gabby to stay
to do a group breakup the group breakup
so insane
that was so insane i think he's gonna go
down as the most hated bachelor of all
time for good reason
and like the girls came hard on him bro
they [ __ ] they tore him up everyone
online hates his guts
and um
[Music]
oh my god he's just such a douche i was
screaming at the tv the whole time did
he make up with the third girl so that's
the most [ __ ] up part because everyone
hated him they're like [ __ ] this guy
he's leaving alone nobody wants to be
with him
and then in the final episode
they they revealed that he got back
together with the third girl
which is so stupid i'm so mad about that
i wish she would have stood her ground
so hard because now i feel like she was
she was girl bossing so hard yeah and i
was like yes susie leave you deserve
better yeah and she's like that's my
boyfriend or whatever she said at the
end i was like you've got to be [ __ ]
joking i'm sorry i cannot believe she
took his ass back and after they sho
after watching the show back you really
see how manipulative and disrespectful
he was to those other girls telling
everyone he loved them begging them to
come back
just nasty dude and he he [ __ ] them
both told him he loved them and then the
same two girls he [ __ ]
24 hours whatever earlier he put him in
the room and then dump them together a
group dump
[Laughter]
jesus christ it was amazing it was the
best reality
it was so good i don't watch it but you
know who spoiled it for me
you're dead oh yeah my dad you have that
tweet yeah it's a discord that your
response cracked me up last night dude
my dad i cannot believe my dad i'm
me and ela are hyping this up
all night waiting for theodore to go to
bed we go downstairs we got our popcorn
and i go i'm surprising twitter my dad
this is like right after it airs okay
this is spoiler time
he goes you get nothing
and i'm like okay they all leave him
i was like you son of a [ __ ]
you
like how dare you not spoil and you're
like
you got silly zombies you've got zombies
that's true
yeah you got gary gonka and my dad is
you got gary goggin that sounds like a
disease
my dad is someone who cares about
spoiling he's the kind of guy who's like
don't talk about the game i've watched
you get whatever yeah
spoiled by the official bachelor
instagram which i was so mad about
because they posted a spoiler before
west coast aired how
that is i was i was unfollowing i did
not want to be spoiled because all of
the alum were hyping it up so much i was
like what's going to happen
but i think it was contractual
i said dad delete this i swear to god
you just [ __ ] spoiled it i haven't
watched yet i'm so mad i'm blocking you
what the [ __ ] he didn't even respond to
me did he
i don't think he didn't delete it either
did you block them no gary gonca dog
i gotta block them you got gary you got
conquer
dog
anyway if you guys don't watch the bat
well the good news is
the two girls that he uh
by the way all the girls were amazing
those two girls
i was like
queens all of them except susie who took
him back
i'm excited for a bachelorette i think
that was a good move joe millionaire
style so the two girls that got uh
dumped
are now doing a a season of bachelorette
together
i can't wait wait yeah that's gonna be
good
together dude
together
same guys polyamory two girls same guys
so they eat okay got it i'm assuming are
they a couple now and they're like
i get what you're saying now you first
started
right and when you first said that i was
a little thrown off
i think that's what clayton wanted
clayton wanted
he was ready to sister wife them he's
like i'm in love with all through you
and i just can't decide it's like dude
and he's telling that to all the girls
like they don't want to hear that
yeah unbelievable man such a good season
so shout outs to the bachelor nation
this week what a rollercoaster at
let me pull up a picture when when he
started
messing up at the end he just started
sounding like such a dumb
mor he's just such a oh
such a dumb he's like this big dumb
[ __ ] human he's like a can of spam in
human form
look at this guy he just slammed out of
a
can of spam
damn
which is like a
i say this a lot he's a meat popsicle he
really is
you do you find him handsome sam
no
i mean he is like he's literally just a
dude he looks like every dude
well he's like tall and jacked so i
thought he looked like uh shaggy when he
took the buff potion
that's funny
wait i gotta see a full body
dude he he he reminds me of the guy from
umbrella academy the dude who's like
half ape oh yeah
yeah the guy who wha he's like half ape
he's like [ __ ] huge yeah he is huge
some of his looks were wild too man
show jackie took the buff potion for
real
man you're pretty good on scooby-doo
lorian
we've been
trying to tell you
yeah i know that's what i'm referencing
a whole
but i was also you know what i was
thinking sam
i was like this is why incels
this is why red pill exists because this
guy clayton he's tall and jacked
other than that he is
he has no personality
he's not funny he's not interesting i
don't even think this [ __ ] has a
job
yeah i don't know that's all he has
going for him
i just i was annoyed he's he's so
entitled like he thinks like oh
who he literally was like before i admit
i slept with all y'all who want to marry
me
exactly
it's like because he's tall and handsome
and he's used to people [ __ ] throwing
themselves at him and that makes me want
to
get the butt and ready dan
same
you know
people were saying that the uh tone is
annoying maybe change the sound to
something like that
that'll be more annoying
no it only it only works with uh
the tone i'm afraid
i agree the tone is kind of triggering
if you're listening yeah like that
[Laughter]
anyway clayton's the worst such a douche
you know i'm red-pilled after this
season straight up
i feel like everything that you said
about him
applies to the
to the other gender as well though
yeah that's true
you're right
there's a lot of i'm back to blue pill
then
just saying i'm just saying it's a
universal human quality for
you know
dumb himbo or bimbo if you're like if
you're like perfect body yeah
you can just be like you can skate by in
life if you're incredibly attractive
it's
just a sad reality
i often say if i look you know if i if i
look like pewdiepie i'd have a billion
subscribers by now
if you were into saying subscribe like
pewdiepie
say what pewdiepie is to subscribe in
all of his videos okay and he made a
meme out of it
well i've been doing that and i'm still
blowing well he's been doing it for like
10 years you got to catch up
you think that's why
i mean the sub to pewdiepie meme
definitely blew him up by like what are
you getting like 40 million within that
time
let's see where we're at on subs see
we're not we didn't even get there bro
we still need 150.
we're done
we're not done stop it ethan we got like
a thousand subscribers after we said
that
no we didn't i'm looking at it we got a
hundred
nah i'm looking at it we started at
uh
eight thousand
nine hundred no we didn't
we were at nine thousand five hundred no
you
i'm sure i'm sure we started at 8 000. i
had the
the studio open love watches this he
watches the analytics before he sleeps
whatever
thanks for subscribing
whatever can i give it a shot
oh hey olivia's here oh hi olivia what
you doing hello
i was listening to it the whole time
yeah you want to join us olivia
[Music]
oh just everyone's trying promo to sub
but i thought i'd like to give it a shot
go ahead suck yeah go for it zach okay
hey how you doing welcome and thank you
for tuning in into the h3 podcast how
you doing my name is zach lewis let's
give it up for our host mr ethan klein
for the best content
for the best show for the best
everything quite frankly
please smash that like button and
subscribe to our channel
because this is a beautiful and
wonderful place thank you zach
i'm getting the wedding didn't say hit
the bell didn't say turn notifications
on that's a [ __ ] face that's too much
no i don't total [ __ ] fail i'm
getting um
getting a wedding singer vibes from that
one i was getting like 99 cents a day
could help provide a meal for this child
vibes really that's bad a little too up
no i thought he did good i did great for
99 cents a day
this dog
[Music]
in the eyes of an angel
for once subscribe you can save this
poor starving african child
look at him
we're filming him
we could give him food and help him
but we're not
so that we can ask you for money
[Music]
look at this poor girl
if only you would subscribe
she would have everything in life
but you choose to be [ __ ] stingy and
not click that button
and the other person is poo pooing
[Laughter]
all right i'm over this [ __ ] i don't
care
um
what is this
i want to say uh
um
teddy fresh x rick and morty
rick and morty
rick and morty rick rick rick rick rick
rick
this thursday
rick and morty
thursday
it's all 10 a.m
pretty exciting
so what does this saying someone met me
at denny's where i farted on him or
whatever
some lie about me
1800 points i met ethan and he's a
complete [ __ ] he was sitting in
denny's by himself
i said i was a huge fan he told me to
[ __ ] off while his mouth was filled with
pancakes after that either started
screaming at the waitress for more
pancakes and smashing plates on the
ground dude
again you know be funny if that was true
like the one time that was true
because no one would believe that if i
was just at denny's smashing plates and
screaming at people
do you know the demi lovato twitter
story from a few years ago
i'd love to hear it oh my god let me
pull it up it's a fake
like narration of meeting demi lovato
one of their
um meet and greets let me grab it so
this is not a real no it was so fake and
so funny
[Music]
demi lovato fatty fan claims lovato
called her fat bullied her
but
what is this website is this a real
article
this was probably published before they
realized that it was fake or something
so they actually published this sure
looks like it that's awesome is this the
is this what you're talking about yes if
you zoom on it it is one of the funniest
things i met demi lovato recently my
name is madison and this is my mng story
uh i met her in october 20th of this
year and it was horrific she was rude
not classy
and she lost a long time look love attic
i think that's the fan base
robotics robotics
i guess i've you know what her fan base
is now called
um
yogurt
they're the yogurt yoguard ticks now
right
i walked into the 350 meet and greet to
say hello and she replies with that
i shook it off because i thought maybe i
heard her wrong as i was she joking
listen fat
as i approached her and asked to do my
pose she stared at me at my blank face
at me blank face i continued talking you
saved my life i say you're the reason
i'm alive today she looks me dead in the
eye and says you'll die soon enough
fatty
and then whispers obesity
i started crying i had never felt pain
like this and she started laughing and
said are you crying
stop it stop it now and she flicked my
vagina
the photographer took the picture
and i headed out of the meet and greet
section and that's when demi started
speaking
whale to me
i still can't believe this happened i
cried writing this i wish this weren't
true but demi lovato is in fact horrible
person so they actually let me read the
article yeah did they really
i don't think anybody actually ever
believed it but after they posted this
they posted a fake screenshot of demi
messaging them and it just said delete
it fat
i said thanks for exposing me on twitter
fatty
not today fatty not today
i mean that's so good hold on
let me read the intro
it says uh
demi lovato is facing some very bizarre
accusations a fan on twitter is claiming
she was bullied and called names because
of her weight at a recent meet and greet
this is real they're writing this from
yeah i think they bought i think they
took the bait dude they got zonked
i got those arms
yeah that's some boomerang [ __ ] right
there
well
there you have it
how about some fresh uh
fresh fresh and fit fringe
back on cringetopia
oh man this is gonna be bad
women are not built to handle masculine
problems we are being vulnerable with
what's a masculine problem
like i already have questions what's a
masculine problem itchy balls
your dick hurt my dick hurt my big hurt
god damn it my dick hurt again
prostate cancer
yeah right
that's true barbados
coconuts and barbados women are not
built to handle masculine problems we
are being vulnerable with a woman is
some of the worst advice that modern-day
women give to men because if i sit there
and i cried you oh my god my life is
hard blah blah blah blah
yo you're so dumb bro that's not what
being vulnerable is
you dumb [ __ ] you are so stupid
you're actually dumb
and i wish you wouldn't be such a coward
and you would come defend me with
coconuts and barbados who's your co-host
and not rollo tony whoever the [ __ ] that
is some ponytail wearing chin strapped a
weirdo
not trying to get involved with that
dumbass
not because he's smart and i'm scared of
him because nobody [ __ ] cares
who he is
wait they said they'd debate us ian
just the two of them
they said they debate me in hassan
without rollo tony browntown
okay let's do it
i'm down
bro
i'm down okay
you might sit there and console me for a
bit but deep down you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're gonna go and find something so
not sure i know
all right so you're saying that what he
you you're you're this guy is so his
brain is i actually feel bad listening
that he really thinks women
anytime he opens up to them they're just
thinking about what a [ __ ] he is like
what did your mom do to you bro
every time a woman says something told
me rolls his eyes i wonder if that's a
masculine problem
i still don't know what a masculine
problem is
um
that's that's so [ __ ] up that he
actually thinks that that's really sad
this thing is incorrect
powerful
again this is a common example of women
saying one thing but doing another
they're saying this right now because
it's politically correct why do you
think you know what they think
his mom must have like
made him tuck his dick between his legs
and like walk around the house like that
or some [ __ ] like really [ __ ] him up
you know what i mean
dan uh yeah i do
i saw dan doing this i don't know if you
were disapproving what i was saying i
was
i was doing something else
yeah you know what i mean like his mom
made a mangina around the house and
[ __ ] him up
this guy manginas
prove me wrong
prove me wrong
this man wears women's underwear
at home tucks his dick back into his
butt crack
and looks at himself in the mirror
and he says i'd [ __ ] me
would you [ __ ] me
say you can cry to me you can be
vulnerable to me etc but deep down if
your man came to you and was crying on
your shoulder saying i don't know what's
going on her vagina's going to him can i
finish can i finish
yeah it's we know where you're going you
don't
he's this guy man
her vagina's going to dry up she ain't
going to want to [ __ ] with him anymore
she's going to look for a stronger more
capable man because women are designed
to look for security just because they
cry once bro hey man i can't are we even
talking about crying he's like just
saying
take care of your problem like just
talk about your day and [ __ ] tell you
how many times we brought girls on the
show with their own they tell us on air
i one time my boyfriend cried in front
of me and i never looked at him the same
this guy loves nipple torture i'm sure
of it
this guy walks around with nipple clamps
and a mangina and he gets off
sad really
coconut zimbardo says coconuts and
barbados is there but i think he's had a
frontal lobotomy or something
i don't think he knows where he is
i'm trying to think but nothing happens
someone said i'm dating long distance so
i just mail my tears
interesting
perfect dude
ah
i can't get over this guy how are they
real
people watch this [ __ ] man
fraud and fat that's what people are
calling they're not fat
if coconuts and barbados is fat then i'm
[ __ ]
humongous
let me see how these guys are doing
fresh and fit podcast
no
they got rolo today on bro
oh [ __ ] no views
five hours no views
that's gotta be a bug right with rolo
tony i mean that guy's
red bullet tony has
unbelievable what are you afraid of you
by the way
oh he called me ian
it's called debunking the body count
doesn't matter myth let me guess it's
about women's body count and not their
body count
that's a
very difficult are you guys very good
it's live
oh it's live oh let's do inception
what's up [ __ ] bro the h3 podcast oh
they only have 600 people watching dude
nobody cares about you guys bro
more concerts
can we have a live debate it's difficult
to light them up it's easy
so this way they know there's no
shenanigans
there's no you know what i mean there's
no sleight of hand
let's just have a live debate with rolo
tony who's dressed like a 14 year old
look they literally have a sign on their
desk begging people to do their page
like that's right
well i told you i was going to wear a
white t-shirt for the for tonight's show
with the girl so like maybe i'll
disappear and you wear a black t-shirt
and you'll disappear there you go
there you go man back man so um hey
coconut do you mind that rolo tonic
literally called you dumb
like a week ago on his video
so a quick announcement guys before we
get on today's show uh patreon.com check
us out over there get all the behind the
scenes content also go ahead and pick up
our boy rolo tomasi's book the rational
mail yes it's uh amazon link is below
and also guys get the merch
restaurantpodcaststore.com
and uh what else what is this channel
called fresh official
yeah
it's time for ads let's uh
oh no yeah they're getting wait hold on
this is good they're the wednesday show
debating with uh rocky sabo and uh kevin
saveo we have charlie from cultivate
crypto is on with us as well yes
let's get on the phone with freshman fit
live
cross
[ __ ]
podcast bonanza bro
and uh we're doing a red pill nft we'll
talk about that later but they're doing
a red-filled nft dan aren't you excited
about that
very good letting everybody know what's
out there and it's easier the future man
yep and that it's a red pill lions right
yes
red pill live baby so uh guys so for
delay by the way um we were doing a
little bit of research making sure we
had all our stuff ready to go because
today is going to be a very important
episode and they're getting tomatoes so
okay so the other day right let's go
down my mind
i'm captivated
last week
um
someone had sent me a video a supporter
uh a supporter
and there's this this this woman this
girl man harpoons yeah uh okay whatever
guys if you want to debate here's your
chance okay just call
thank you
oh we can get hasano's live too this
could be interesting we could set up a
whole thing
all right let's take our sponsors and
maybe we could set up a debate who knows
magic
happening here today
but
um
we've got oh abe you have a burrito in
your honor before we thank sponsors
this is abs burrito.com
yup
so let's take a look here av's burrito
dude there's a twitter page there's a
instagram page it's getting out of
control
burritos that are not more famous than
abey's burrito
look at that david delbrick's burrito
um
and and justin bieber eating the
sideways burrito
let me get that burrito on cameo
never forget what went into abe's
burrito ah yes
i feel like something's missing here
maybe it's like what what is it just the
veggies and
i feel like the there's something
missing
well i added a little something
and that's why i didn't show the full no
but
okay whatever let's not
this is all
sidebar thank you to our sponsors liquid
iv
okay
liquid iv is helping you accomplish your
new year's resolution
what's some new goals you've got well
how about
staying hydrated
and uh changing up your fitness routine
liquid iv is helping you
do it all it's the new year's in no way
better way to kick off 2022 the making
sure you're feeling your best
um listen staying hydrated
the key to happiness
fix all your problems in life
done
liquid iv one stick of liquid iv in six
ounces of water hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone and liquid
iv has a bunch of great flavors
like watermelon lemon lime strawberry
pina colada and more dan you're ready to
chug some uh liquid i don't
what flavor we got today dan we've got a
little bit of hydration multiplier uh oh
the watermelon one i like this one
that's the hydration formula because
there's a lot of cellular transport
technology i'm not gonna get transported
into [ __ ] hydration it sounds like
alien tech
it is
the roswell crack from the uh from the
1950s they extracted the stuff they
found that on rosalind reported not at
rosalind at roswell roswell yep no no no
no actually there's roz lynn oh that was
more secret only i know
yeah that's actually a very common move
with those conspiracy theorists is they
they love nothing more than one-upping
each other like whatever conspiracy you
believe in
you're just a sheep the real conspiracy
yeah you believe in roswell yeah that's
just a cover for lin
that's the real [ __ ]
well dan is hitting the hydration
formula there's like a a boost with
caffeine there's a boo an immune boost
one with like lots of vitamin c
it tastes great it hydrates it can help
you
get your you know first thing in the
morning before a workout you're feeling
run down actually could someone get me a
immune boost i think i need one of those
oh that's good
thank you
uh hangover it's good for all that
i love it liquid iv
actually each pack
uh
contains five essential vitamins b
three b5 b6 b12 and vitamin
c with three times the electric
electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks it's made with premium
ingredients non-gmo free from gluten
dairy or soy
and uh what makes liquid iv so effective
it's it's a scientific cellular
transport technology
we love that
anyway grab your liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco or get 25 off when
you go to liquidive.com and use the code
h3 at checkout that's 25 off anything
you order when you use the promo code h3
at liquidity.com experience better
hydration today at liquidity.com
probably
and finally thank you to
one of my favorite products
that i use
nightly
curology
curology is a game-changing custom care
a skincare routine made by dermatology
providers they create a custom
prescription cream for your specific
goal specific goals whether that's
tackling acne clogged pores skin texture
dark spots fine lines or anything else
you start by taking a short online quiz
and uploading photos of your face of
your skin
and if it's a good fit they think they
can help
they'll ship your formula right to your
door it's got your name on it it's a
dermatology provided
it's the real deal
i don't know how yours work but i don't
know if that's just what they provided
for me but i have a
they sent me a face wash a moisturizer
and the dermatology provided cream
and i love all the products man the
moisturizer it like doesn't make my fin
my skin feel oily or glossy
and we'll just grab me one maybe
and uh
what do you got for me
okay we'll do this
uh and uh
yeah and the the uh
the face wash doesn't make my skin feel
super dry either so it's really nice
gentle
love it i love curology been using it
you know i don't have time to go to a
dermatologist i don't have time to go
online and read all these blogs but i
take care of my skin
i've got time for that [ __ ] just go to
curology 30 day trial of curology.com h3
just pay five bucks for for shipping and
handling
damn get a free 30-day trial that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com slash h3 to start your free
30-day trial cancel any time
prescription is subject to consultation
thank you took your lg
what do we got here i've got a hydration
and a
[Music]
hydration
immune this is immune maybe
no
i apologize i didn't i thought it was
just the energy one i need more water
though
i'm about to boost me up
you just bring me a fresh
boosted
so um
i want to talk to you guys about your
experience with jimmy lee
oh oh god
by the way let me know if uh fresh and
fit uh
senpai noticed me uh well they put their
uh
chat on sub only mode so i'm sure they
didn't notice you also apparently uh son
texted you
he got the message about oh really wow
yeah so
um
[Laughter]
message travels fast
so they i'm even willing to talk to uh
rollo tony browntown there
cracker
roll
dude they got the they got the super
team there they're talking [ __ ] right
now about uh our girl drew
oh let's watch let's watch let's watch
let's watch we got a lot when i opened
two one of the mods of their channel
wrote in the chat she got hovid19
that's one of their mods ah nice the
fact that she's saying oh you're outside
the club hayden it's like no like we
actually do have the stats we're gonna
go through them right now as far as why
you are incorrect so i don't think
they've ever had this many live viewers
um okay so you want to hit the data well
first and foremost i i just want to i
want to
make sure that everyone knows that when
you have all of 30 seconds what is it 45
second video yeah if that's that's the
format today by the way so uh nobody
watches the two hour full video nobody
watches you're making one right now you
dumbass joe rogan the most popular show
in the world this show gets a million
views
per episode what are you talking about
you idiot
my live streams like unless you're like
yeah nobody watch your live stream
because they suck you're not
entertaining or interesting like a real
dog and you're like a 50 year old
talking about dating advice for 18 year
olds it's creepy and weird you have a
chin strap
hard phallus he's a guild people don't
watch two-hour content anymore yeah make
tech talks they won't watch those either
part of my my group right and if you
watch my full live streams you will
notice that i use constantly use and
cite sources i talk about tim burkhead i
talk about david buss i talk about
jordan peterson news as well
i talk about rob henderson every single
episode of great thinkers of our time
yeah
i read my conf just kidding
do i come at you with stats because
that's what people are going to come
people are going to hammer me just like
this in a 30 minute or a 30 second clip
to say he doesn't know what he's talking
about no don't don't forget don't
pretend to be a psychologist you're just
some dumbass bro in a basement
if you go and you watch the entire video
you will understand hell you don't even
have to watch just why did you guys
debate me this is a big opportunity
let's do it now
right
we're live there live
this entire video just watch the section
because hassan's ready hassan's ready to
jump on too
come on guys
rolo tony's in the studio
there's chapter markers so that you can
go and get to the section that isn't
they're not opposed to debating you know
right like
they're
they were reaching out to us they they
want to do it
i want to do it too but now here's now
this is a great opportunity
we're here
why y'all ducking heath and hassan
exactly beta
come on what just nobody cares about
debunking body count myth talk to me and
hassan
so that's why it's a common courtesy
right oh should they pick her someone
gave five bucks and they erased the
message okay i see what it is so uh am i
uh
all right they're not going for it guys
beta behavior
here let me text this on back i'll say
i'll say unfortunately
unfortunately to beta
to debate us right now
you know
never be a beta
well they are there i thought never be a
beta but here they are being ever do it
is death it is death
you know
it could be magical experience
fortunately sorry i'm pulling up the
stream i want to read our chat
yeah nobody can accuse us of having a
less
better run stream
all right you guys want to talk about
jimmy lee because this was pretty epic
um as you guys know jimmy lee
um
friends of the show
he is a how would you call him a shop
associate of the show i would say right
let's not say friend he's more of a uh
he's an acquaintance character on the
show yeah he's in our goof game
he's a friend of the show i'm going to
embrace that
sometimes you have friends wait until
you see the footage yeah after that
after what we experienced ethan i don't
i don't know man
that was pretty rough he's been on the
show
but jimmy lee he tells shocking often
racist just horrific uh jokes
i'm i'm afraid he's gonna get beat up
the stuff he says to people is just
beyond
now
you guys he's been begging us to do uh
he texted me and zach what like i don't
know
yeah he emails me like 10 times a day
yeah he called me like five six times
there was one week where he called me
five six times a day
just
brigading and harassing
did you ever answer well eventually yeah
we filmed with him i mean it got so it
works yeah that's why he keeps it up
yeah
well um
so
we did a segment where cam
love ian
and zach went out to to do some jokes
with him his whole stick is he goes up
to random people on the street and just
offends them
um
zach you he was taking your un under his
wing was that the idea that that was our
plan unfortunately that really didn't
fall through
because um
he uh
he brought his own
filming crew yes he always does that
right so
in in our minds and what we've discussed
with him
and made it very clear that this this
was mutual that i was going to come and
he was going to teach me the ropes
however this was not the case
whatsoever he totally hijacked our shoot
yeah he uh
it was just jimmy he just he turned on
into jimmy yeah i that's what i thought
it would happen he's kind of got one
track yeah and you know that's it that's
all you're gonna get he kept getting in
our shots his filming crew kept getting
in our shots and um
there was no stopping this man and he
kept he kept telling me you're not funny
zach you're not doing this right he said
that to you yeah you're the mentor was
he serious
he kind of alpha dog zack a little bit
yeah
so what well okay that so what was ian
and well love your swedish you're
visiting what was your impression of all
that went down
uh i mean my view of the american people
has been very very reinforced people are
resilient uh probably if you did that in
sweden you get your
i i say swedish people are pretty calm
but
doing stuff like that would not fly
sweden
i'm telling you we even did that in new
york the first time i met him we were in
new york and you know new yorkers have a
reputation yeah i'm surprised nobody
nobody swung at him
well we had these two big ass security
guards sure
but were people getting pissed or were
they just kind of playing along
i mean it's so dumb so
it's hard to take seriously some people
were some people were mad yeah
so ian what was your take because you
were there behind the camera
oh i mean it was
it was it was a radioactive situation i
mean in jimmy's words it is dangerously
funny yeah
so he i mean he keeps saying the same
jokes like 20 times even though
different people
like god loved the guy and he treated us
to breakfast was really nice and he
treated us to lunch
but
we were supposed to film with him till
like seven o'clock
oh my god and it hit like
i was done around like one o'clock i'm
like how are you gonna do there's
nothing when did you meet him we we met
him at nine so he wanted it
he wait
nine a.m nine a.m and he wanted to do
ten hours yes yeah he wanted to [ __ ]
that ten hours shoot so ten hours by one
o'clock i'm getting like i'm done like
i'm just
[ __ ] yeah four hours is enough with
jimmy
so it like four o'clock hits and e we're
all just like
this is enough we gotta there's too much
and ian was getting upset i was upset
love was just for what were you upset
about ian
well
we were just pissed it just wasn't i
could tell everyone was tired it wasn't
really you know we were trying to film
as zach said
ever just a lot of backs turned we
couldn't get a good shot
jimmy is bringing us into restaurants
stuff you're not comfortable with he he
flagged down a bus and made them stop
and he roasted every person on the boat
you went on the bus
no he made everyone go out he had them
leave the bus what how did he do that
wait what kind of was what kind of bus
was it like a hollywood boss yeah so he
stopped the hollywood bus yeah he
somehow convinced them all to come off
he sees all of them a lot of people were
like i'm not doing this and then he got
on the bus and roasted them too oh my
god it's not like comedy he's like
saying you're ugly yeah oh yeah he's
calling him he sees the poor the bus
driver and he gets him to pull over he's
like hey zz top because he got a big
long beard
it was just horrendously bad and i think
the part that really pissed him off was
he people would come up with him to take
pictures of them because obviously you
have a camera crew and bodyguard so
people think you're someone right
but we would get noticed from the show
like oh my god that's ian oh my god that
zach does love and he would get kind of
pissed at that really yeah we lost a
couple of fans for sure
oh no
there was this ticket boy in like a
ticket you know cube whatever
and i heard the like speaker like is
that you love h3 yeah and i turned
around and yeah it says and then i
pointed him out to jimmy lee like
there's a fan in here and he just goes
up and like calls him like
he doesn't fly
no no
[Music]
it was bad and i just stayed after
because i'm the audio dude so i just
like sorry about that dude
well if you're a fan of the show you
know jim that jimmy he was laughing but
that was rough good evening it was dare
i say the worst day of my life well
since i started working here this is the
first thing i voluntarily like skipped i
was like i can't do it i cannot do it
even dancing out of it
alone in the office yesterday we should
just i'm actually seeing a decent amount
because we have a lot of relatively new
fans and jimmy is kind of an old meme
jimmy is a uh
comedian
uh who has been part of the h3 lore for
years now there was an old h3h3
productions video made about him
because you guys discovered on youtube
some of his his comedy sketch his sketch
comedy stuff right that's that's how it
all originated so the original story
this is so crazy
is that he's a dentist he's actually a
very successful dentist he's rich and
one of our fans member of the subreddit
said
i was at my dentist
and when he finished he handed me a
dvd right of his sketch and said go
watch this
and when i watched it was the worst
craziest thing i ever saw you have to
watch this and they posted on the
subreddit and then we started making
reaction videos to it
and it is incredible i mean you could go
watch those on our ethan and hila
channel they're still up one [ __ ] up
dentist it was called which he told me
why he kind of like got rid of that
it was totally tanking his business yeah
of course he can't look dead
you can't have a dentist passing out mix
tapes to his [ __ ] like he told me he
lost a lot of business and like
he's like burying it
he did that's like he's putting the
kibosh it's buried like it's gone and to
add that he's not only a dentist he's
the owner of like seven or eight dentist
businesses he spent like four grand on
this whole day oh he he keeps telling me
he drives the rolls-royce no he's i love
you yeah he's a multi-multi-millionaire
the thing with jimmy he wants to be
famous so bad
that's his like goal he doesn't care how
he doesn't carry any willer way by the
way i should also mention he's like 70.
he's old this is not like a young like
this is not a young man who's ready for
hollywood not not to give off too much
of the sauce from the video and what we
have upcoming but when he's in makeup i
mean it's just
ethan i've i've never seen some [ __ ]
like that did he put a shitload of uh
makeup on what do you mean he had a full
makeup artist and you know
his hair is thinning which he can't help
but he's old yeah he's getting old yeah
he's like he's like i got a receding
hairline so what the makeup artist did
is he painted on a hairline
and it looks like he's like ready for
the mortician or something
yeah so
here's what crazy dude here just to show
you guys now this was like from 10 years
ago so and i just should give you guys
an idea
this is a trailer i don't know
apparently he erased them all but
the thing is he still do oh this is like
a trailer
but um he still does his comedy so it's
not like he's retired
he he will
do anything to get famous yeah you guys
you got by the way you guys might feel
bad because we're making fun of him but
we're
he's literally this is how we always
talk about him and he literally emails
us a hundred times a day yeah well he
also he ends that it's gotten to a point
where he goes by a different alias now
so he's creating new aliases to email us
he made a fake manager yeah
that he admit to zach was him
he's like hey i'm jimmy lee's publicist
or whatever we're like that's you jimmy
right he's like yep it was the name like
i won't say but he um
it was just [ __ ] hysterical so
this we've done a lot with jimmy over
the years he's you know
he's a great sport he doesn't care
he loves it he loves the attention so i
mean
we try to do what we can for him it's
like a make-a-wish for jimmy at this
point
yeah i guess i just remembered any
relatively more recent fan if you saw
the roast that we did for ethan's
birthday last year uh he was one of the
participants right yeah which we had if
you watch that you may remember him from
from that clip so uh
let's let's see what this is i'm [ __ ]
up tanist
i mean he's saying he danced
he dusted full screen i'm not singing
man i'm just a tennis
someone made a dramatic uh one thing
counts in this office
pull teeth
you gotta pull teeth you hear me you
idiots
[Music]
that's where the money is let me hear it
apg
always
hello hey how you doing i got to make
some pains
i need an hour
oh no
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute stop it
this is star wars music i just realized
okay wait let me um i gotta find some of
his street comedy to give you guys
a clip
okay good yeah so he he was in town two
weeks ago doing the same [ __ ]
with like the same crew
so there's a recent one
this one is from march 10. yeah
let's see
look what we get in la for ten bucks
turn up the quality too it's like oh
yeah sorry megapixelated because you
know he always filming
okay well the last one i assumed was it
would just look like that but this one
there we go all right let's let's give
you guys a taste of of of
what's to come here well there's
actually a really funny wrinkle in all
this
is that a keemstar
fan
apparently
we saw on twitter
a fan encountered all that was going on
and then was like yo i got yo keemstar
you want an exclusive clip of me
roasting the h3 podcast crew and then of
course game's like send me
and it's just jimmy lee
a guy who by the way when keemstar was
trying to cancel me was being like
ethan's just mean to this old man jimmy
lee it's poor poor
um
which we'll get into i'm excited to
watch that by the way cam cam was saying
that it was the most chaotic day of his
life
the final edit is going to take some
finesse so i'm sure yeah i just unmuted
your mic if you okay you can hear me
yeah i gotta say we got kicked out of at
least eight places yesterday
and
they were all fancy restaurants and such
and it was you know this is gonna be a
nightmare to edit but it's going to be
gold at the end of it so okay i'm going
to do my jimmy should be thankful you're
the one editing it now we got four and a
half hours of footage yesterday so it
might take a little bit but uh this is a
this is a really good uh hype up we're
doing right now we we went through hell
ethan oh i i've i i know because i've
done it myself bro
right i was high i made i
when i before i knew much about him
we did like a whole series of reaction
videos to him
on our ethernet and ila channel when we
lived in new york because he's from new
jersey so we met up in central park and
we kind of did what you guys did today
with him and it blew my [ __ ] mind i
sent a time stamp i don't know if you
want to look at it from that video from
the restaurant yeah and it's one of my
favorite moments in h3 history yeah so
this was my first encounter with uh
with jimmy lee and it was just
mind-bending it was unlike japan
who who can embarrass the waiter that
much better than that
all right but tonight i want to be on
the bottom okay and i want you to be up
on top so ethan's going to come over the
bunk beds okay this way i'm going to be
he's holding her arm
[Music]
thank you
look at his face
i'm good
that's okay this is normal
i want to ask for the record
right away
what was
[Laughter]
the that of me that's the real deal
unscripted uncensored and that's what
people want me on the street billy get
off the streets the jersey outlaws on
the streets okay but what about that
whole thing about like the asian girl
that like asian jokes and like having
sex with her that seemed like kind of
inappropriate
it was very appropriate
it seemed like kind of like awkward no
brian was really digging it brian just
got instead of an election erection this
is the stuff that's gonna hit is the
street comedy and the fun stuff with the
people i think what i just saw was one
of the most awkward things i've ever
seen
i'm not just saying that to be ironic
we're fine
that was insane we're gonna end up in
jail i mean i was just
i had to confront him on it there and
then because i i had never been put in
that situation before yeah i mean
i just the man is on he's [ __ ] insane
he would say he has balls of steel
he's got he's he's not him
he's insane i mean i don't know what to
tell you there's another gold timestamp
at 7 40. if you want to show that sam
says they went through literally a
thousand of those situations yeah that
was nothing dude no they're they're i
don't know the way
so here we go into central park
look at this guy it's like a shark dude
next with him
oh my god he's a he's a maniac what
maybe i didn't say anything oh
where are you from
where am i
i'm trying to stop him sorry my father
didn't take his medication today that's
that's what the stick i was doing oh
really yeah when you're ready
so smooth from the footage i saw i'm
very impressed so why was he and he was
complaining that you weren't that you
were like ruining it because i would
call him out on like his jokes yeah his
race is okay good that's good he's like
you're ruining it you're good i'm glad
you did zach i'm glad because
you need a straight man otherwise it
just is psychotic like crazy he's too
much dude
yeah at a certain point i was like i
can't we got to stop
all right
come on
i just tried to talk to him you know
yeah i wasn't there to do schtick or
anything
are you from the hood or can i borrow
the hood
i'm not sure about this
i'm just not sure what to do because
jimmy
he gets he does his thing he married and
no the cameras aren't even looking at
him
i don't know if i should intervene
because we were just supposed to walk
around the park and chat like get to
know each other
and this is the result of that
i mean it sounds similar to what they
were explaining
but he doesn't have a lava and there's
no camera right yeah i mean the whole
premise
for yesterday which i know was discussed
heavily because zach's not lying i mean
the dude calls him like three times a
day so i heard a lot of these questions
and the premise was that he was going to
be little jimmy and he was going to be
like
mentoring him or whatever and pretty
much just immediately
that just went out the window and he's
just walking around insulting everybody
that he encounters yeah it's kind of the
opposite of what you're showing because
you're saying he had no camera pointed
on him then
this time he was trying to like
trick people into thinking he was famous
so he would be like all right camera
guys get out first then security we're
gonna wait two minutes then zach and i
are gonna get out everyone's gonna think
we're celebrities and then we're gonna
start he kept saying isn't it great
being famous isn't it great he would say
that in front of them he just he's off
the [ __ ] rails so we would be like
sitting outside the limo waiting for
jimmy to get out
and then he all these people are taking
photos well you guys were what you guys
were going around in a limo yeah yeah i
did a limo
all these people are thinking like
looney or someone's about to jump out
and then jimmy would launch out and just
be like hey this is my boyfriend zach
hey what's up fatty yeah it's [ __ ] like
that
he went up to a girl in one of his uh
street comedy videos it's just it this
was stuff we used to uh
we used to clown on him for
um he goes up to a like a larger woman
and be like hey what's up you really uh
whoa save some food for me inside huh
we got a big
we got a big one we got a big girl we
got a big girl
he's like he's like hey i know what you
had for breakfast the whole buffet oh my
god like you said that uh he's like uh
you really have inflated
oh yeah and he has this one pose this is
disposed he does that everything [ __ ]
time that's his pose and he kept saying
do it like this zach do it like this but
like so he was mentoring you well
in photos but not like
going around saying hey this is an
approach this he totally hijacked the
shoot you know it's crazy if you just
look at his face like you could see he's
bald
like you see his dome and then there's
just like hair on top for some reason
like he's bald and then there's some
mayor on top madame tussauds wax figures
man
yeah so i'm actually curious how old he
is he he's he he he's not a young man
he'll never admit his age i think he's
got to be in the 70s
easily yeah something like that
like mid 70s yeah that seems about right
so um that's the lore
cam says he's 54 no
that's not possible you wanted it you
can't be serious no i don't think i
honestly have just that's what he threw
him here
that's what he told him he told him he's
54. i'm a 74. i'm gonna i'm not he's
really agile though i know he's a good
shape doing all this [ __ ] i agree
i doubt he's 70.
bro trust me he is in his 70s as old as
[ __ ] i'm texting him right now no but
tell him he's got to tell you the honest
truth zach
yeah
so you see we have a we have a
interesting relationship with jimmy yeah
but it's he's a character what can i say
he's one of a kind absolutely never met
anyone like him in my life that's for
sure
for 10 bucks
jimmy lee the jersey outlaw dangerously
funny in hollywood
pandemonium and mayhem it's going to get
nuts what band are you in guns and noses
oh
so yeah he just he literally just
the meanest [ __ ] he's an [ __ ] he he
used that joke on me
dude that's the other with the guns and
noses yeah he he got me good oh damn you
got [ __ ] wrecked
jimmy that's just mean dude he doesn't
give a [ __ ] they should add a tail
jimmy lee the jersey outlaws wheeling
dealing girl stealing limousine riding
jet flying and it's gonna get nuts i'm
pretty sure his i remember his breath
really stinks too
like when you get really close to him
did any of you guys notice that or no
no he gets really close to his
he's a soft talker
he's he's a very soft talker but the
credit he did smell decent he did smell
good okay good
[Music]
who's this guy
who was the guy you're with last night
the big israeli guy
who's on the bottom who's on the top i
am on the top all right i'll tell you
what you do next time if you're on the
top your bottom get a bunk bin
you're a see that one wasn't bad that
joke he did probably 10 times yesterday
yeah really that exact like all of those
jokes same thing every time he meets a
couple that's the magic of street comedy
yeah he kept saying
you got to do it like ten times with one
joke to get one to hit
don rickles is his idol he wants to be
famous and don rickles i could see he's
trying to that but there's only one don
rickles and also don rickles was like 50
years ago so yeah
ripped to the goat he's even way meaner
than don rickles though
donald's had an arm
yeah sometimes like
two young girls walking by he's just
you're ugly
straight up he did that nothing else he
did that yesterday he's like look at you
you're [ __ ] old you're like 15 year
olds
and we had to tell him don't do that to
young kids he he doesn't like ask for id
he doesn't do any of that nah
so we had to stop him at some points
which is we just don't know why he got
i literally stopped being friends with
someone last semester because they
called someone ugly and i was like i
haven't called someone ugly since i was
like 10. yeah i don't think we can be
friends anymore jimmy's 100.
that's that's wild i didn't know he was
just screaming at people that they're
ugly yeah yeah fat
uh who'd you sleep with last night like
you just did you know let's see that was
saint bernard
oh jesus
girls
i have to be honest with you
i've never seen and met
two more boring people
and now i understand why
there's no dates
what's the joke there jimmy he's there's
none he's just being an [ __ ]
and after
after he calls someone ugly he'll just
walk walk away and then he'll gather up
with the guys or with us and they say
yeah that went very
well bro you just called someone ugly
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] bored he kept asking like is the
audio rolling because yeah he was
wearing two laps he was wearing from he
had two lives
and from his crew
he's like yeah can you hear me okay like
every five [ __ ] minute bro
i could hear him pee one time too
how was the stream was it soft or strong
no hardest [ __ ] dude oh crap oh he has a
good prostate
i asked him like jimmy how's your pros
apparently good by the sound of his pee
yeah how are you doing
how are you doing
how are you doing how are you doing
how you doing can i ask you girls a
question
can i talk do you guys speak english
yes don't don't get angry but did a bus
hit you on an angle what happened to you
you see that
he said that one about 30 times
yesterday
he's gotten worse i feel like i don't
really i don't feel like he used to be
this me just straight up mean to
everybody i think he's like mentally
losing it or some [ __ ]
yeah
yeah this might be a cognitive decline
yeah he also said that he wanted to
become famous and we asked like
we kind of went into details about
becoming famous and he's like i don't
care how just whatever give me fame
i just find it i find it so interesting
that at his age he's still so determined
this guy managed to have a long
extremely successful career in life
the guy is truly an enigma i mean he is
one
person of seven billion truly well you
guys are really exciting people it's
like watching a casket warp hanging out
with these people
jimmy lee the jersey outlet the chinese
theater in hollywood this is where they
make all the wonton soup
i'm going to tell you a joke that's
going to make your boobies fall off
looks like you already heard that [ __ ]
said that one about 40 times yesterday
everyone is just so mean
it wasn't this bad before what's your
name
nice of you to come out your pajamas
it's a nice outfit you can work the cod
candy machine at the carnival it's a
nice outfit what are you smoking are you
vaping
it's just the kids
how you doing where was the job
the editing is just insane by the way
you know his shoots are 11 hours long
this video is six minutes
right well you gotta yeah pick the gold
the gold nuggets i mean holy [ __ ] dude
what happened baby it's a nice
put a candle on you play restaurant
jesus christ looks like a tablecloth
where's your husband
i have no idea i lost him yeah i wonder
why how do you know he's not hiding
oh my god we're applying for the drug
drugs
this one definitely won't make the final
cut he asked that to some lady yesterday
oh man
oh yeah that was fun
she said
he passed away and he said
oh are you sure he's not hiding
right so [ __ ] up
holy [ __ ] ethan the amount of trauma
we went through this is worse than i
imagined it's horrible
it's it's
bad dude
all right enough well we have so much to
look forward to brutal
um
we have so much to look forward to uh
with the edit i'm interested i think
your guys's video will be interesting in
that um
you'll get you're i'm interested in just
seeing your guys yeah i know the
observer it's like yeah we gave the
truth
the true jimmy lee right he gave the
gate we didn't sheltered we just we just
we set it like it is
well you guys went through what i did so
sounds like even worse potentially i
don't know that
you i don't think you guys understand
how awkward that restaurant situation
was oh yeah
because i can't imagine
i never incredibly uncomfortable to
watch much less be there
unbelievable
oh so let's get to the fan apparently
real real quick oh i need to i'll
if you want to do that i can set that up
but um
there's just a really interesting uh
super chat we got a few minutes ago
uh from raven i literally just got out
of a coma and love is here and now ela
has a baby
i have and i have tbi so i barely
remember the past year
well i hope
you weren't a frenemies fan because i
got something
yeah i'm still here well it could be
maybe maybe he hasn't been fighting if
they were in a coma they could have
missed frenemies entirely that's what
i'm saying
lucky them
interesting sorry
um here here's the tweet that someone
sent to keemstar pulled up on the h3
podcast crew today and got video
roasting them if drama alert wants so
here's jimmy zach ian smirking which
never happens
and love what happened here who was this
guy he was a uh
lack of a better term he was a little
[ __ ]
and um he was you know look i get it
he's probably a fan he was with a camera
he was just looking for do some [ __ ]
and he just
like told a bunch of people to scream
keemstar
okay
and we turn around and
it it jimmy got pissed because it
interrupted his joke
he was telling what you'll see did jimmy
roast him
you'll see
okay we'll see wow
who got roasted my friend don't take on
jimmy
what's interesting is the i i think this
person is clearly a fan because they
knew who jimmy was almost instantly oh
they're a fan of ours yeah
all right well anyway let's move on
we've got a little clip you said dan i
don't see that
huh
you said we have a preview oh
cam was editing a a teaser oh here it is
all right i've got it
here we go guys and anytime you want me
to queue up this uh phone call yeah you
can you can queue it up uh give it up
it's up to give you an idea
who are these people we just like
keemstar and we think ethan's lying
hypocrites wait he came out with his own
camera yeah he was he had it all on
[ __ ] you know
handheld [ __ ] he was vlogging
you like positive for a second you
really listen to the the keemstar
keemstar uh screech is he can pubert
he's pre-progressing by the sound of it
people we just like keemstar and we
think ethan's lying hypocrite
what the hell
look at jimmy look at him he's all mad
it's just chaos surrounding jimmy
all right look at jimmy's hairline there
you see that black line love you it's a
shadow you're muted wait oh no that's
makeup yeah yeah that's makeup dude
awesome
who are these people we just like
keemstar and we think ethan's lying
hypocrite
i wouldn't mess around with h3h3 they're
here he's a [ __ ] why not because that's
zach that's right you start here
his team's right you start to pull up
i'll get kids
it reminds me of me doing my tour
portion at my apartment exactly
balls haven't dropped yet wait so you
think he's a fan of ours or keemstar
he's a fallen fan like the rest of them
oh you think he's a real fallen fan oh
for sure he knows a lot no i think he's
still he knows a lot of lore i think
he's still a fan
who are you i'm just here to say that i
think that ethan's lying hypocrite i
think that the more time there's
probably more times that i've tried to
interrupt you ethan's tried to say the n
word in a video
isn't he a little [ __ ] up i think
you're a little funny
zach you got a little a personal there
bob i he this this yeah i was throwing
shade and
i mean
he was just a little [ __ ] prick you
know
i was cracking up when i seen the photo
first on twitter because zach is so tall
he's just standing in front of everyone
like a unit basically he is exactly as a
unit yeah
you have some issues sorry what is he
doing i find it interesting that jimmy
when confronted with like a real hater
like where's the roasting jimmy right
he's being hatched
he does actually it's my favorite oh
give me that it's the only time he was
genuinely okay jimmy let's go yeah bro
innocent random people i think you're a
math major you got a lot of problems did
you go to college
nice
one he's so funny dude he's awesome you
didn't go to college
i'm just wondering
shoot the son of a [ __ ]
shoot him you're german shoot go get the
rifle and shoot him yeah go get it
pull up on me
what did he say he told him to shoot him
shoot that son of a [ __ ]
what did the kids say oh shut up a [ __ ]
couldn't really catch what he said
shoot him you're german shoot we'll get
the rifle on shooting yeah go get it you
say you're german i'm just saying yeah i
missed that the first time it's always a
little bit of a you won't have a racial
component this guy out of his misery
or something yeah buddy
why'd you just like spend it on a hair
transplant again would you give him [ __ ]
could you give him 12 bucks to go away
no the problem is [ __ ] no no you know
you know i just i can't get over his
voice it sounds just he does sound like
a kid oh yeah well it's funny he's going
after jimmy lee
i like that i mean i love the conflict
it's interesting let's see
yeah what's up make like a tree and
leave before the security guards knock
your ass out is that your comedy
no my comedy's looking at your pecker
[Applause]
okay jimmy let's go
let's go jimmy you just got [ __ ]
actually roasted like an outlaw bro
what's he got now
buddy i'm 16.
oh now you're 16.
the way that he says that
i'm 16.
you know i thought you wanted to be a
big boy and come and challenge jimmy lee
now you're 16 when he just dunked on you
let's hear it again let's hear the 16
again
what's up make like a tree and leave
before the security guards knock your
ass out is that your comedy
no my comedy's looking at your pecker
see this is where jimmy comes in clutch
that's the thing you uh he needs to know
you gotta you have to point jimmy to the
right people right right
random bystanders who are minding their
own business right
we need to you know we need to harness
jimmy against our enemies we need to
bring him in and and then talk about
people we don't like now i will say the
next thing jimmy says
not good i have no idea
okay let's let's try to dissect it
buddy i'm 16. yeah you're 16. and let me
tell you something
okay wait
wait i want to hear
it's like a schoolyard fight well that's
what it's like
i want to hear that buddy i'm 16.
[Laughter]
we could tell
wait wait i want to hear what jimmy says
no you're 16.
and let me tell you something about you
did the pimples come from hershey's you
like yourself and available with the
radio online and whoa whoa
whoa whoa wow is there captions can i
turn on captions
i don't know if that'll be yeah
says i can
sometimes the captions really come in
clutch here i just i don't understand
the joke that he was trying to portray
yeah you're 16. and let me tell you
something about it did the pimples come
from hershey's you like yourself and
available with the radio online and play
with yourself
did the pimples come from hershey's or
did you lock yourself in the bathroom
with the radio on
and play with them he just goes what
[Laughter]
i don't know on that one
you got him good jimmy he was speechless
it makes no sense
and let me tell you something about you
did the pimples come from hershey's so
then the pimples come from hershey's
[ __ ] yourself
or did you lock yourself in the bathroom
radio atlanta
with your late radio on loud with your
radio on loud and like yourself and play
with yourself
it's just
verbal diarrhea at that point i don't
know it's just a wall of words that
aren't connected
i don't know
[Laughter]
you have a lot of problems did they come
from wherever she was
do they come from hershey's
[Laughter]
he's so angry though this kid is so
angry you're only 16 man why are you so
angry at me i like what what did i do i
i think he was just having a little he's
trying to get clouded up i mean he
immediately
started tagging keemstar trying to get
so
you know like what is uh so fun i love
this whole thing it's just great
a good lawyer super cuts
let's get a good lawyer and see super
cuts sue super cuts for him
see that one wasn't bad but this is good
when the kids being a dick yeah yeah
yeah don't say i called myself and
that's horrible so if you go up to a
random person and say hey go sue super
cuts
not funny no not at all this kid being a
dick is funny yeah
you have a hair transplant
there they are
come on over yeah lee nice to see you
what's your name
jimmy just wait he's off karen and
lucian where are you guys from
everywhere everyone watch him proceed to
be meaner to these nice ladies
look what we got today for 10 bucks zach
[Music]
yes
what was that joke i didn't get it
they're pro he's calling them
prostitutes
i would have liked to watch them argue
more that was that was magic man that's
awesome but that's a w for jimmy lee
though because he said he had a trans
hair transplant but that's just makeup
dude oh that's really
yeah
he was he kept asking us like when he
was in makeup he's like he's like can
you see the keypad zach can you see it
and he had a hairy brush it over and he
got it like sawed it over yeah i mean
dude it was crazy and sack answered a
little bit hesitant at first so it's
like tell told the makeup dude to put
more powder
so good
you guys got that on film we got
everything oh yeah
this is going to be a good this is gonna
be so good
so i feel a little bad for cam who knows
to relive this [ __ ] well apologies to
everyone on the street
seems like you guys did a good job
trying to reel him in or apologizing for
him that's good yeah
shout out to the heckler that turned out
pretty funny shout out
there you go
oh we have a fan calling uh go ahead put
them in put them through okay one second
i let him in
[Music]
get a post on the subreddit
but
he says he's my number one hater
that's not what i said it says help a
hater battling a brain tumor and heart
failure
not funny obviously but i was laughing
at the hater that's my boy my number one
hater
what's up
man
what's going on what's your name
uh my name's patrick patrick patrick
patrick how are you doing bud
i'm hanging in there man i'm uh
you know like i'm i'm kind of up against
the wall as i wrote in my post but
i'm i'm
full of hope and like trudging through
all the doctor's appointments doing what
i got to do
uh to get healthy and
you know
hopefully uh hopefully i can pull
through this thing and
like this whole thing is just a really
good dinner party story in a few years
you know
well
if you can survive that jimmy lee
segment
then i'm pretty sure you can
you know
it reminds me of some of my italian
family back home in chicago oh yeah only
without maybe without a proper uh
education
hey jimmy is hiding he probably went to
harvard or something he's saying his
family oh yeah yeah wow
wrapping him on the wrist for being
disrespectful to women you know my
grandma once knocked me out with a
salami for disrespecting my mom true
story that's most italian
mommy nice that must have been a hard
slaw on me
none of that soft stuff oh wow
yeah oh yeah my nonna didn't didn't mess
around dude
so what do you what are what are you on
like uh
what's the situation are you on like
chemotherapy and all that
not on chemo we did uh
we did an operation about five months
ago roughly six months
ago gamma knife procedure
whoa gamma knife
yeah dude uh you should look it up it's
it felt like i
left planet earth and was on the
starship enterprise for for
surgery um what they do is
they take what they normally give
in a six-week course of radiation
and they condense it to about a half
hour
so it's like a fire hose of radiation
um and the the the reason it doesn't
like you know damage all the tissue
between
you know my skin and my tumor
is that
fire hose gets split up into like 200
and i think it's like 280
like little individual straws
and so it's a it's like 200 and
something
little tiny beams all around your head
that all converge on a single point
inside your skull so it's kind of like
surgery from the inside out
wow i'm looking at a picture of this so
what you said in like a cat scan kind of
thing
and they yeah that's
an mri
yeah and they shoot lasers damn how
that's crazy
what was it like
during the procedure did you feel
anything or was it just kind of yeah
yeah dude i actually
this is like a deep cut reference but i
leaned over to the nurse and asked the
nurse if she was familiar with uh
the tolstoy short story the death of
ivan ilyich
that is
it's a deep cut i'm sorry i'm a fellow
englishman here so you know yeah
but it's all about how you know this
this rich guy needs to come to terms
with his own mortality in order to find
happiness in life
and so i asked her are you familiar with
that short story and she looked at me
like
clearly not
and i was like what i'm telling you is
in order to commence with what's about
to happen i have to be fully comfortable
with my
the likelihood the possibility that i
might
die right now
wait was that a risk of that procedure
not not
you know only like you know
a very a fractional percent of people
die from that procedure but the problem
was
for the procedure they screw
they like screw bolts into your skull
here here and then here and here
um i tried to send dan a video of it but
they screw these bolts in and then they
lock your head in
like a brace
and then they put you in an mri machine
and map out the tumor
like super precisely
and then they put you in this other
even even smaller mri machine
um that shoots the the gamma radiation
which is the same radiation the whole
that created the hulk oh
yes indeed
i wore a hulk t-shirt from my
god
so as you were getting blasted with
gamma rays in your brain though did you
experience anything like what was that
like as it was happening yeah so it's
mostly it's mostly the like the the
trauma that happens when they lock you
in yeah because they like click you in
like you're a lego
to this device and then they put you in
a tube
that is not like you can see i'm like a
pretty
you know big guy and they put you in a
tube that that's not one size fits all
like they had to like
push my shoulders in and breathe
and so
the the thought kept running through my
mind like
in the event of acts like in the event
of the zombie apocalypse i'm gonna die
in this tube because i can't get out
um
so
that part was terrifying
um and then other than that it's just
like really loud
and uh kind of like disorienting
and then the
about 20 i think of patients that
receive gamma knife
have what's called radiation spillover
which is when like the radiation gets
localized in the tumor and the hope is
that it destroys the dna
so your immune system kind of flushes it
out as it tries to grow
um
and we're still kind of in like a hope
you know hope that's the case
place right now um
and then uh radiation spillover is when
you know it's what it sounds like like
that radiation leeches out of the tumor
into healthy brain tissue
and that's been
that's been like a real
shitty you know part of the recovery
um like it created like
uh aphasia
so like the words going from my brain to
my mouth get kind of jumbled
sometimes and uh
some acute memory loss and then like
weird symptoms like i can't like
i'm not driving right now because the
state of my heart but
um like i would get lost on my drive
home from work like you're just still
working bro
dude bro
i'm so glad you what the [ __ ]
so i got this diagnosis
in 2020 like in the thick of it you know
like covid land
uh big time and
um
i was starting i just started a a coffee
company with my
fiance and my sister-in-law
and kovid
made it so that we had to you know
furlough like
30-plus employees when we got the
mandatory shutdown
and i was i was the guy like i had to
roast the coffee and
my my sister-in-law and fiance you know
we had to keep the business afloat so
i actually roasted every single bean of
coffee that that we sold
for
basically all of 2020 into 2021
um
until we could bring in
a badass roaster who's better than me
but i just had to do it so actually
there's a photo
i sent two days after the the radio
surgery i described
i was in in a roastery roasting coffee
that's great
swollen like my eyes
but you know it like it kept me it kept
me sane
you know and one of the
one of the shittiest symptoms of the
tumor was
the sound of thunder in both of my ears
for like
eight months straight and and zach
could probably relate to how horrible
this is but like
it was sensitive to sound so even if i
tried to like put music on to calm it
down if i turned the music up the sound
of thunder just went up exactly
yeah that um that's awesome i mean
imagine constant thunder like and i'm a
i'm a
former musician i've kind of hung it up
but
you know music's a huge part of who i am
and
there was no relief but the only relief
i could get like the only ambient sound
that comforted me was this the sound of
the roaster kind of drowned it out the
thunder wow
oh yo uh we should get can we get some
of your coffee i want to try it out
no dude like seriously watching you
taste the taste of my coffee we should
do some uh
gamma knife coffee dude
it's all it's all gamma knife coffee
yeah let's do it dan you're in touch
with him let's get some coffee we'll do
a testing sure oh man i hope it doesn't
suck because i'll be really that would
be really sad
samantha's off screen she's a little
camera shy but she's like oh it doesn't
suck okay all right i'm gonna hit that
[ __ ] how should i drink it with cream
with sugar or straight the [ __ ] up
what i like to say is there's no wrong
way to enjoy something good
and so much butter is bad dude
butter's dad you're butters dad isn't he
the guy with the coffee shop in south
park that's tweak oh tweet sorry
tweets dad tweet yeah
there's a fine cup of coffee
uh patrick
the whole foot soldier army's behind you
i know it's amazing dude i'm gonna reply
to everyone
in the in the subreddit but what's the
uh what's your coffee company called
uh we're called fiddlehead coffee
company in rochester minnesota all right
we're gonna buy we'll buy some
yeah but you don't need to
so like the the reason i wrote the thing
the the
um sorry brain tumor moment the reason i
wrote the post
uh on reddit
was like
that we have a coffee right now that i
like i believe into my bones
to do some like real good in the world
um and i don't want to go too long but
the short of it is
my best friend from childhood um was
from russia and his dad
i come from like a super evangelical
part of the chicagoland area
um in the same way ab comes from like a
a culture that he kind of
holds in his heart but has
left
um
but uh uh
which i admire you for by the way you're
the man no i appreciate it thank you
dude whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa listen if
you're gonna call in you can't be
complimenting the guys you can't
you can only compliment me if you're
gonna call in
no you are
i mean you're the hairline king well
thank you thank you thank you yeah there
we go
super long story short my friend
uh his dad and he and his organization
uh ran the runs the largest missionary
organization to the former soviet union
and so over the last like 25 years
they
networked like
they were headquartered in kiev like in
in ukraine
and they networked like churches and
like
bakeries and cafes and the huge network
for like immediate humanitarian relief
for
refugees
and so i reached out to to dimitri my my
best friend and was like hey i want to
help your dad how can we how can we do
this and he and i brainstormed
uh roasting coffee for ukraine
so i have a coffee right now that's like
super select
um small batch it's roasted by oh here
it is i'm on your website it's oh yeah
it's lava ukraine
yeah which means glory to or long live
ukraine glory to ukraine baby
yeah and it's
every
uh
every bit of the prophet is going
directly to um
feeding
and clothing and housing humanitarian uh
out of ukraine
all right and it's totally impactful
every 50 spent provides a week of meals
for a family let's go man fiddlehead
coffee dot co this is the website we
found it now i'm going to buy i'm going
to buy everything we're going to do a
whole taste test when we get the coffee
if it sucks i'm going to spit it out you
want to hear what he said about mr
beast's chocolate the other day yeah you
heard what i said about mr b's chocolate
i'll be honest with you patrick i don't
care that you've got a brain tumor
uh like i want i want to send uh some
chocolate before
some coffee and some chocolate before uh
love
leaves for sweden okay because minnesota
has some bad ass chocolatiers that do
like direct cacao sourcing from the farm
like bean to bar all right and wow
and so we have some
bang and all right
let's do it and thank you we'll be in
touch
to be continued we're gonna do the taste
test patrick foot soldier army's got
your back
you know you've got the uh you've got
the uh
you've got the feet of a thousand uh
warriors
stomping on you i don't know if that's
good or bad
nice chatting with you buddy appreciate
all the kind words
real quick just end with one thing
uh as of today i'm going to refer to my
tumor as ryan kavanagh oh and i'm going
to have
we gotta take him out
[Applause]
we gotta get that tumor to pay your
legal your dog your for your uh medical
fees
[Laughter]
mayo mayo clinic i have to shout out the
mayo clinic because i live here in
rochester and like dude
you should come out and do like their
executive
um health care plan they do like full
body scan again like straight up star
trek [ __ ] like the dalai lama comes once
a year for it
uh
but it's like it's like he's so afraid
of death
he's just getting a reincarnated anger
that's what i'm saying dalai lama it's a
little
little face
whether or not he's going to be
reincarnated you're right yes that's
right yeah because diana china's you
know [ __ ] with tibetan big time but
i'm gonna try this coffee the branding
looks beautiful
all right patrick
i'm gonna we'll be in touch once we get
the coffee okay stay good be good stay
strong keep your spirits up
and stay blessed okay we got you
buddy family family family family family
family family family family family
family family fam family family stop
stop
[Laughter]
thanks bro you guys take care okay we'll
talk to you soon
all right you too thanks season
appreciate you buddy
legend
patrick firing a brain tumor out there
brave guy
brave guy he's getting gamma knifes
gamma rays in his [ __ ] brain
actually saw
there was a super chat or member chat or
whatever from uh
somebody that said they are
getting gamma knife surgery later this
year so huge props this has been very
informative well good luck
good luck guys so all my gammon offers
uk
that's cool i mean gamma knife sounds
cool as [ __ ]
i hope it works
i did not know that was a real thing uh
one of my favorite bands has a song
called gamma knife and i always just
thought it was like just kind of like a
sci-fi like cool sounding thing i had no
idea that was a real procedure so so
shout out patrick i'm i'm excited to try
his coffee
uh yes sam said she uh ordered one of
everything
nice it's on its way
nice it's already in the mail we love it
what a guy good guy
great guy
25 euro donation high foot trooper
cancer researcher here precision
medicine i just want to let you guys
know that there's a lot of researchers
trying our best to help people like
patrick be cancer free love you guys so
much [ __ ] cancer
shout out to the cancer research cancer
researchers fans of this show
i know who's watching this what
how is that possible
thank you shouldn't you be watching uh
um
big money podcaster
what did mature people listen to
uh fresh air with terry grove fresh air
yeah exactly
i can do fresh air fresh air with ethan
klein today in ukraine everything's
[ __ ]
[Music]
that's basically what the news is
russian soldiers continue to kill
civilians and also their army is [ __ ]
incompetent and they're getting owned by
the ukrainians and they're getting
pissed off so they're bombing civilians
today on fart air
ass air
fresh air
you know what i'm saying yeah i got it
in other news
jay powell
is increasing
the uh interest rates
because our economy is
[ __ ]
up the stock market defies all logic
stonks go up and [ __ ] you poor peasants
[Music]
[Applause]
what the [ __ ]
this is ethan klein with fresh air in
other news
i took a massive [ __ ] this morning
[Music]
it was slightly black
i'm gonna keep an eye on that oh
somebody said your
fresh air your show is more like dead
air dead air
that's jail that's good
what else is happening i [ __ ] my pants
today
in other news
uh joe biden is getting ready to address
congress today
about his balls are starting to sag to
his knees that man is old as [ __ ]
what a stupid sound a [ __ ]
joe uh joe biden last night tripped over
his own ball sack
this is ethan klein listen here fat so
what i got a little saggy balls saggy
balls they're touching my ears on my
saggy balls
by the way footnote
you know this tag that comes on teddy
fresh clothes it's a sticker i don't
think a lot of people know
that this thing is a really nice sticker
comes right off
right
okay doesn't damage that
and it's like a really nice puffy
sticker it sticks really good
i'm just saying i don't think people
know that
just saying just saying yeah i'm
surprised how many posts i see on the
subreddit people are like i had no idea
again they have like a million of them
they're great good stickers
stick your finger stick your finger
so
let's see
good types
bob's basement final episode i wanted to
watch talk about this for a while
wait the show isn't ending they're just
leaving spotify
they
essentially say it was a mutual decision
ah they got fired
that's awesome definitely not
between them and the company being too
exclusive bro it's a free platform
it's not exclusive
well maybe they mean because they were
because they were exclusively on spotify
right yeah yeah i mean that
that is a dumbbell but they say the
company spotify is too exclusive
yeah that seems weird
here let's see
they're like bro we're not paying you
you get like 10 views
no hard feelings on either side um
it's just we yeah it's time at the end
of the day it's business right yeah that
is yeah
yeah aka they're like we're not paying
you right
this all leads back to the aiden ross
stream
he lost everything from the lost
everything yeah banks is like we need to
end the show
right well do you think banks did or
spotify ended it because it sounds like
spotify said we're not paying you i'm
not sure but i think the real reason is
that stream i can't say for sure but oh
definitely
i'm surprised banks still associates
with them it's embarrassing and to be
honest there has been a lot of guest
hosts i think banks has been
kind of m.i.a on that [ __ ] lately yo
you're in trouble that crypto [ __ ]
it's it's just business and um you know
there's uh there's other things that we
want to do in the future and
uh
i just want to shout out to uh dan over
at spotify oh dan and a few other people
uh that worked on this show
uh we appreciate you we know all the
time and effort and how hard it was to
to deal with us cause
we're probably
i mean i can at least speak for myself
i'm probably the most toxic [ __ ]
on the internet so
there's it's been challenging
[Laughter]
i think actually jimmy lee might have
keemstar beat
although
maybe not
you know interesting well those meetings
you're definitely the uh the [ __ ] in
the conversation most of the time yeah
well it's not just that it's like a lot
of the
i don't know that was a big hurdle for
us it's like me and keem really were
here when nobody [ __ ] even knew you
could make youtube videos and make a
career out of it and here we are you
know in conversation we were one of the
first spotify original podcasts like we
made another wave like
it was so oh my god you can't be taking
credit
the only reason they they knew they
wanted to do podcasts and they said
let's get a cheap little [ __ ] show
to test beta run this keemstar is taking
credit for all of spotify podcast
movement
cool like i remember meeting the spotify
people and do you remember like we sat
down on that first meeting and they were
like so do you guys want to go on jimmy
kimmel
and i'm like no
there's no [ __ ] world where even star
goes jimmy kimmel
jimmy lee thought he was going to be on
jimmy kimmel yesterday oh yeah that's
strange wait he did what did he say yeah
he
maybe we should say this but
tell me he we walked because we're in
hollywood and we walked by his studio
and there's people lining up so he
thinks because jimmy lee's walking by
with cameras that one of kimmel's
producers gonna recognize him
yeah that's like the childhood fantasy
of right so i broke it to the candy
store and then a movie or broke into the
production company yeah right
and then the security told us to leave
so he comes up with this brilliant idea
he's like well if we keep walking
they can't necessarily stop us so we
just kept walking back and forth with
him roasting people that's like wow kids
in department stores singing and singing
hoping that a recording oh yeah
how many times
approach i think four or five yeah four
or five
it was insane dude my guess is that he
wants to go there
because people in the queue can't leave
you know so they're forced to listen to
him
and that's where we got recognized the
most from the podcast and that pissed
him off so much
oh man i can't wait to see this this is
going to be spectacular
keemstar and jimmy kimmel man that'd be
a [ __ ] sight
so keemstar tell me about the time you
falsely accused someone being a
pedophile
amazing 10 year old fan right away thank
you
so much so do you guys want to go on
jimmy kimmel
and i'm like no
his laughing just it's like i've never
heard someone laugh so insecure in my
life
yeah he just exhaled so much
[Laughter]
bro he's sick
he was shocked because i'm like no we're
internet people like we don't want to go
on any talk show
like it was just it's cool so it's cool
it's cool that they believed in this um
it was a little too banks is like bro
you're so lame i can't do this anymore
too exclusive and two like it just
didn't make sense um on both sides both
both of us us and spotify are totally
happy with with the outcome and um
really grateful for the experience
yeah that's good banks is being trying
to be professional you know
banks saying they were indefinitely in
in infinitely large and impulsive and
came saying ethan stole the idea for
frenemies oh yeah
yeah keemstar okay let's hear it it's
good
you see um shows like impulsive that
started around the same time as ours and
ours actually came out the gate
you know infinitely stronger and bigger
than impulsive if people you know have
been to so what that just means your
show sucks people don't want to watch
your show tuning in for that long you
know in the early days the first few
episodes we did ninja
uh ksi we did adam 22.
um and those [ __ ] cracked we did them
on my channel on my youtube channel and
those were cracking and um i don't know
again no hard feelings this is just a
decision that everyone's kind of come to
mutually and it doesn't mean it's the
end of mom's basement forever i think
we'll prob probably take a nice break
and kind of readjust and oh it's over
there's no way the show's coming back
i mean if banks wanted to make a podcast
there's so many more interesting people
you could do it with the keemstar yeah
for sure
he does talk about how it's like
spotify is too exclusive or something
but then later in the episode he says
that maybe the show might come back
on like web 3 some sort of thing which
oh
exclusive to me nft podcast yeah yes
baby
i mean snoop's in phase now maybe it was
new
maybe that'd be more that'd definitely
be more interesting
yeah
it figured out but but this show and ip
are amazing for me like i p stop it
what i p
two idiots talking about
the ip is cool but but keemstar gotta
go i hope you're the one that owns the
ip
like you know
i i'm about doing [ __ ] before anyone i'm
about actually creating like a wave
right so
er in the early days when we were doing
trolling stuff nobody did anything like
that like and then we built an entire
genre on youtube how does banks tolerate
him he is just full of bluster he's so
insecure he's just bragging about
himself
how do you talk to this guy on a weekly
basis doing this you know trolling and
gaming entertainment content and uh when
i launched dramaalert there was no
competitors like i was literally the
first drama channel when we did mom's
basement it was before this whole
podcast wave it really was yeah well
actually let me take it back the podcast
i was on prior to this which was baited
yeah was set up with with me and clown
being arch enemies there was not a
podcast with two enemies going to war
every day on a podcast like that didn't
exist like i started that wave we had
ethan klein on he liked the format and
you know
zoe wait
yeah sorry
listen came i'm sorry to break it to you
but saying the n word on xbox live is
not revolutionary actually that was
pretty commonplace before you started
doing it so thank you
i'm pretty sure that's where the idea of
frenemies comes i cannot believe he
thinks that baited inspired frenemies
now that is [ __ ] incredible comes
from and so with mom's basement we were
the first ones to like really i mean we
could go all the way back
this is so embarrassing
what is mom's basement other than just a
couple of dudes talking
what is revolutionary about that
why are you so cute when you talk [ __ ]
he's so embarrassing
who the [ __ ] bro well i guess that 16
year old who can't store rules
ethan's changed
things are you asking why he was so mad
that's why why because mom's basement's
ending he's having a bad week 16.
mom's face was ending
oh scoob
me and blade had a video podcast like
way way back but i mean me and you kind
of set this podcast you've been around
forever but it was kind of it was kind
of like you either did youtube videos
and that kind of content or you did
podcast you were like an older like
comedian or like
how about instead of just um
talking about how great you guys are and
how you revolution the genre how about
you just make a good uh content that
people actually want to listen to so
your shows don't get cancelled
yo we got dates bro we got dates
wait teams oh we got dates
keepstar came on our podcast april 10.
mom's basement appeared may 2nd that was
their first episode
keemstar was on our podcast
may
an entire year before wait what's the
whole year yeah yeah april 2017.
so who inspired who
i'm not going to sit here and talk about
how i revolutionized the genre
but if you want to say i didn't
revolutionize the genre let's be honest
but you came on my [ __ ] show
and they made your show a year later
you [ __ ] stole it [ __ ] just saying
just say it
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom
send that gif
yeah he's talking about baited where i
stole uh
for enemies from send keemstar that gif
boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom
i don't care
this is funny to listen to this kid
like
you know somebody in the sports world or
fashion world and specifically had a
podcast geared toward
you know a certain specific demographic
we definitely were you know we're one of
the first to to pop in and just say
we're going to do you know and
everything internet internet culture
truly revolutionaries
i think it's awesome that they're just
like as their podcast is just becoming
completely irrelevant just talking about
how awesome they are
keemstar doesn't know what a metaphor is
okay i believe that now that i'm
thinking about the stuff that we can't
talk about i want to talk about
something so bad i got to tell you about
this one thing
so i'm gonna i'm gonna say it in a
metaphor right
all right okay
yeah he does not know what a metaphor
let's hear what he has to say
well i
okay
do you know uh like back in the day like
an old russia there was that uh nuke uh
nuclear plant that blew up like what's
the name of that bro you are so dumb
i'm sorry but i can't do this
should i i need to proceed through this
i think
i think you're going to want to hear
them
you know what i'm saying
or something something
i don't know what you're talking about
this is and they're wondering why their
show got cancelled
yo do you remember that nuclear power
plant that blew up ah what is it called
uh
corolla
in russia by the way which which was in
ukraine right yeah
chernobyl of course
but i love that banks doesn't even know
what he's talking about
no
oh man you definitely know what i'm
talking about this is a great story so
far yeah oh chernobyl you're talking
about yourself yes yes yes okay yeah
wait is that never russian is that in
russia oh my god banks is so much
smarter than keemstar yeah he's
infinitely smarter yeah and infinitely
more successful yeah yeah that's
ukrainian yeah but that was in the old
soviet union before before russia was a
or ukraine was a country true true
so old when that no when yeah he goes
old russia
no
but okay keep going everything blew up
remember this is a metaphor
yeah this is all a meadow this is a
metaphor so let's see where this is
going
an extended metaphor you might call it a
literary term
like a lot of people died like in and
like you still can't go there there's
still radiation levels like it's bad his
adapt went there and he absorbed so much
potassium that they advised that he
never eat bananas again for the rest of
his life
oh my god he went there why did he go
there he went there for a music video
and just like as a video like we went to
chernobyl
because you can talk what the [ __ ] are
they saying this is the weirdest
anecdote ever obs he absorbed potassium
from being neutral noble he got powers
is that that's something that happens
i i think what they're
saying is that he absorbed so much
radiation yeah he said potassium well
potassium is is radioactive and there's
a tiny minuscule amounts of it in
bananas no but he said yeah there's
there there is another truth where this
is coming from but i think he meant to
say yeah some wires are getting crossed
so he said he says
he absorbs so much potassium which is a
vitamin
right but i believe it potassium
don't eat any more bananas for the rest
of your life
i'm sorry but what the [ __ ]
like there are certain parts you can go
but i mean i know what he's saying he's
saying he he absorbs so much radiation
that he can't even eat bananas anymore
because bananas are slightly irradiated
right yeah
i risk and they like
do monitor your like
radiation levels and [ __ ] and they do
like it they do like
somebody donate 100 nuclear power plant
chorizo
chorizo yeah
i think he's [ __ ] stupid um
this is you know in school you learn
when you make a metaphor you want to be
really
clear it's important not to get your
metaphors mixed up
you want to make a very clean metaphor
to drive your point home so so far
we're in uh old russia
the plant uh chirizo
and we're getting too much potassium
where are we going with this oh
and uh yeah his biggest takeaway has
adapts just adapt right his biggest
takeaway was they told me to just stay
away from bananas
so i don't even like bananas bucket
anyhow i'm gonna tiptoe around this
because i want to say this so bad but it
might get cut out i don't know but there
is
a
much do they not even have editorial
control of their episodes who's going to
cut it out
well
no one
at all because well it's clearly
uh
in the ukraine right now it's the
biggest one in europe and there's
fighting going on right there and
there's a live stream and there's like a
fire in the facility and they said if it
blows up it's going to be like 10 times
worse than the first one that we were
talking about yeah chernobyl
the way he just phrased that it sounded
like this one time at band camp there
was this fire
social for sure oh yeah so
what again what is the metaphor here is
like i'm gonna speak in a metaphor so
you know that nuclear power plant that
blew up so there's a nuclear power plant
right now and there's some fighting
going on in there isn't that crazy
i'm assuming he's getting to something
that something isn't like that oh no
that's it no no that's gonna happen even
if it's like a little bit like not even
if it's not perfectly accurate what you
just said it's still cool to talk about
like and like
wonder about you know what do you guy
are you i mean it's incredible they
understand each other i'm just hearing
coconuts and chernobyl yeah yeah so i'm
here
bananas and chernobyl bananas
[Laughter]
wait
what the [ __ ] how did they he's like yo
that's really interesting and cool like
dude that was a specific analogy and
it's cool to talk about man that was a
cool metaphor bro
he's like yo we're gonna do a little uh
we're gonna do a little current events
right now so get ready this is going to
be this is going to shock all you what i
love about this too is this whole like
discussion clearly came about
uh
in
theme store while recording the episode
keemstar he's a keemstar keemstar i
think i said keemstar what does he sell
what does keem store sell
candy uh yeah
carnival passes uh cotton candy
uh
um
yeah i think he was just looking at his
phone while they were recording the
episode and just saw something on
twitter about
this incident at this nuclear plant the
fighting near this part this uh decided
to just start rattling off about it let
me tell you about bananas someone said
uh i wish people weren't so like
like weren't so [ __ ] i don't know
everybody's on it stop it stop just just
taking this this stretch here
wonder about you know
i wish people weren't so like
like
i think they're like why where was our
show canceled i think he's got mad
[ __ ] cotton mouth yeah dude
off his ass which is why this
conversation is this is this is such a
stoner conversation yeah did you get
them tonight
dude they going with no crap right now
they do one tag
it's clear ever since they got brought
up from spotify they just dropped the
ball completely they don't care at all
well look he put it on his main channel
at first they had interesting guests so
of course reviews will be great yeah
challenging podcast i've always said is
getting past 20 episodes when you've
exhausted all your resources all of your
connections and then you actually have
to make a show
that's when that's when you see if
people actually want to watch this [ __ ]
or not
had sex in the tree house
on edge it's [ __ ] the internet sucks
right now the whole [ __ ]
the united okay
just just listen to this i it gets it's
just i'm sorry but this is poetry we
need to launch put this on the dvd and
launch it into space
like weren't so [ __ ] i don't know
everybody's on edge it's [ __ ] the
internet sucks right now i didn't go
back far enough like a little bit like
not even if it's not perfectly accurate
what you just said it's still cool to
talk about like and like
wonder about you know
i wish people weren't so like
blank weren't so [ __ ] i don't know
everybody's on edge it's [ __ ] the
internet sucks right now the whole
[ __ ]
the united kingdom
that
excerpt from banks is truly
it proves his iq status
his mensa membership
it's just i would like to frame that
this metaphor is off the rails by the
way this is high level
uh conversation dialogue has just been
earlier for an emergency meeting of the
united nations security council i'm
reading this from actual like mainstream
media so don't censor me um no one's
censoring you dude nobody cares nobody
even understands what you're talking
about
like why would they censor this what
does he mean you don't have a [ __ ]
point you've been speaking for like two
minutes and you're just like talking in
circles about some nuclear power plant
no like why is that being sent nice who
the [ __ ] are you talking about i don't
even understand why does he think
someone's going to censor i i don't know
i don't know what he's talking about
don't censor me bro but one time my
friend was it went to church what was
that
and now he doesn't have to eat bananas
ever again
because he got so much potassium tip toe
around this topic [ __ ] controversial
it's so [ __ ] amazing between russia
and ukraine forces threatened the
security of the zappos
i can't pronounce the name nuclear power
plant the biggest nuclear power plant in
europe that's the official media what's
the source the the official media
scenario
in a time where it's really
it is important to speak up against [ __ ]
that you don't [ __ ] with but it's also
important to speak up against [ __ ] you
do [ __ ] with oh dude that's so deep
is so [ __ ] have you guys is that what
you're doing right now i don't know is
he doing speaking up against [ __ ] he
[ __ ] with or
against [ __ ] he doesn't [ __ ] with what's
happening
and are we still in the metaphor
do want to see right
because
often times people you know the [ __ ]
squeaky wheels the one that gets the
gets the grease right
it's a cliche but it's very [ __ ] true
it's like most people are really only
willing to speak up and and talk their
[ __ ] when they're bitching about
something or like
did he have a [ __ ] ring go up in the
podcast my dogs are barking because they
they're trained to go off on that
it's awesome comfortable with something
or have a problem with something right
rarely do you see people like going out
on a [ __ ] limb to defend something or
like
what else [ __ ] are you saying
um
what the [ __ ] i really appreciate yo
that what the [ __ ]
wait don't listen to this
he says it's important to [ __ ] with what
you do [ __ ] with and important not the
[ __ ] even more important but then he
makes no stance yeah he doesn't make a
stance and then this golden moment here
listen
i'm just i i have a problem with
something right here listen rarely do
you see people like going out on a
[ __ ] limb to defend something or like
faze aristotle some of that
peace socrates up here
wait okay listen to this
i'm just i i i don't even know
um
i really appreciate all the love and
support
what is himself
turning the pages of a book
that's exactly what i saw
but like face was so incoherent that
keemstar didn't even know what to say
and then you just hear keemstar
chewing us into the mic with just dry
mouth
this is
they're like uncomfortable with
something or have a problem with
something right
rarely do you see people like going out
on a [ __ ] limb to defend something or
like
i'm just i i i don't even know
um
i really appreciate all the
this is the best and this is just we
don't ever listen to this but this is
the final episode so they went out with
like you know
hugh they went out with a big
they put a lot of work in this final
episode and support that we've had uh
over here on spotify from our fans
yeah
so a fun farewell
to your mom's
basement
my mom's your mom mom's basement
that was amazing man
wow
they should do a current event show i'd
actually love to listen to that i want
to listen to them
talk about
i want them to do a fresh air
podcast
well we've once again not talked about
anything in the title
like i feel like we've already done what
how long we've been going oh we've been
going for two hours and uh 20 minutes
um kim pete kanye
yeah
well boom that now you can put in the
title
you said it done that's true
um
we should i guess let's do it on friday
because i just can't get into all this
now get your [ __ ] ass up and work
yeah i do want to talk about that can i
say
apparently i saw in the chat everybody
was roasting me for the way that i said
i gotta think about how to say it now
nuclear
nucle i think i said nuclear nuclear
nuclear nuclear nuclear wait you said it
like george bush nuclear nuclear nuclear
it's gonna grow i just looked it up and
apparently this is a very uh contentious
thing oh here we go dan's gotta no look
there's a there's a [ __ ] there's a
debate on wikipedia about how to
pronounce it so wait what did you say i
didn't even i now i'm like not sure
because i'm like self-aware of how i'm
saying it now i think it's pronounced
funger
if you're all about it i i guess i'm
saying nuclear which is incorrect what's
the j cole song where he says put a
finger in the air
if you want um
that's from his uh allies on me record i
like put a finger in the air if you're
all about it put a finger in the air if
you're allah
nuclear everyone say nuclear go ahead a
b
no say it that's wrong apparently say it
i'm afraid to say it just say it nuclear
nuclear
black nuclear whoever enunciated that
olivia
nuclear
love nuclear
he says it the best this is the best
he's named from here
uh ian
uh nuclear
nuclear that sounds right chicken
chicken
eisenhower jimmy carter bill clinton and
george w bush bush also
said it wrong
so what how did they say it that's
always been confused i think it's such a
common mispronunciation
the way i was saying nuclear is wrong
nuclear
no there's too much emphasis on there on
the second uh why does it i always was
confused why everyone cares so much i
mean it's it's genetic
nuclear
nuclear it's nuc it's nuclear oh i see
that's the misspelling on the top left
nuclear
nuclear nuclear nuclear nuclear nuclear
well i'll try and correct that
after we were just going on about keem
and banks and you're going to come out
and say nuclear
embarrassing delete it fat
put a finger in the sky if you want it
splunker
yeah we have so much to talk about but
like we've already been two and a half
hours bro bro
we keep doing this
it's good there's just too much to talk
about you guys
oh god
so neck on friday we've got
skeet davidson
and kanye we've got kim cringe
poor people just need to get rich
it seems like nobody wants to work these
days nobody wants to work i bet you what
kim if people were making a million
dollars a [ __ ] minute people would be
happily go to work well and i also
when researching that i found out that
apparently uh the keeping up with the
kardashians subreddit
is actually extremely hostile to them
like it's like one you know sometimes
subreddits just randomly like it's just
exists for people that hate it but not
ours
ours is borderline somehow no but but
this is like
because when that video came out that
subreddit compiled
like all of the dirt of like shady
business [ __ ] that
there is i was like blown away i did not
realize people just don't want to work
it's like shut the [ __ ] up
but it's just real
it's extra ironic when you people are
definitely on track record dude people
want to work people don't want to work
at [ __ ] dead-end jobs that don't pay
enough to live don't have any benefits
yeah
there's no good jobs available yeah you
were born rich as [ __ ] with every
opportunity in the world how about you
shut the [ __ ] up and despite that yeah i
just saw somebody mention this in the
chat but this was the one that blew me
away the most this was settled at a
court
however
she was sued
in 2006 for stealing a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars from her boss
people just don't want to work
it sounds like you didn't want to work
you wanted to steal money that's that's
a lot of money also being sued for
unpaid wages and overtime child labor
child labor let's go
i'll tell you who doesn't want to work
those kids
those kids want to work you can learn a
lot from those kids this is actually
going to work guys currently being sued
for a crypto uh pump and dump scheme
yeah yeah
yeah
so we have a lot we should open we can
get into it on friday let's open with
that stuff on friday yeah i think it'll
be good with ela as well brittany's off
the rails jordan peterson update oh um
also
right before the show so much to talk
about a big update on brittany um she's
off instagram she's gone r.i.p we
thought maybe she got banned but
apparently tmz somehow said they
confirmed that uh she decided to delete
her own instagram account why would she
do that she was popping off it was like
an hour before it was like a free only
fence she did that a few months ago for
like one day
okay maybe
maybe she'll be back i don't know
free only fans
maybe she got banned because of those
photos
yeah i would i would think so i mean
to be frank if she wasn't a giant
celebrity oh no those would have gone up
oh yeah like it was way too lewd no
question
for what did you say olivia
she deleted her instagram a few months
ago for like one day and then came back
i did a write up on it and then the next
day
it was back up so
olivia when are you finishing school
when you're gonna be back may
so pretty soon i think i go back and
it's like six weeks or something
all right you doing good you're going to
get good grades on your finals i
absolutely promise okay
don't [ __ ] around and then
i have to do another semester like i did
i promise
okay i plan on succeeding we need you
back here
thank you so much for saying that we
definitely do i need to be here
olivia please stand up miss having her
stand up please sausage fest without
olivia here yes horrible here
it's only here once a week it's just a
nightmare yeah it sucks stand up olivia
olivia stand the [ __ ] up please stand up
i've been listening the entire time
olivia
i've been listening to olivia the entire
time
so foreboding the best drop
olivia uh
real quick before we wrap it up i just
want to take it so wait what's the new
title cause we need to talk about any of
these [ __ ] people
uh
we talked about r.i.p the mom's basement
the podcast is ending
oh that's good
that's good
i'm learning baby i'm learning
that i'm out here
that's good clickbait that's really good
so to the 47 000 of you watching right
now
you're in don't don't spoil it
that's good
[Laughter]
yeah did we ever get in touch with wally
to do a call
no
i went
into the [ __ ] me and maybe excuse me
we went into the [ __ ] depths of
trying to find this [ __ ]
[ __ ] calling him like is that calm in
the morning afternoon
oh people are asking what happened to
the drew uh podcast we had planned for
last friday she had to reschedule so
we'll let you guys know uh
that when that's happening
um well so we'll call it the podcast is
ending or our last episode maybe that
seems too old no that's too yeah that's
too obvious that and that's just or how
about goodbye to the h3 podcast no see
our last steps i don't like i don't like
no how about the choice what about was
perfect because it's ambiguous so what
did davey say
the podcast is ended coconuts barbados i
don't even remember what i said
or the end of the podcast how about the
last episode the last episode
no no no no what did you say it was
better the podcast is ending that's what
you said it's ending yes the podcast is
ending or over
just me like a really serious picture of
me yeah yeah one of these
one of these ones i do yeah
the podcast is ending
all right oh somebody in the chat said
dan is leaving the podcast
but that is daniel
dude that's so good dan wait okay dan is
leaving the podcast is that better i
don't know if that's better that's good
man incredible title dan is leaving the
podcast
but i feel like the podcast is
make even like the haters want to click
on it i agree i think that one's better
go off kane sorry dan it's all good so i
just thought that was really clever
delete it fat
saying that all the time that's a really
good idea though dan is leaving the
podcast
[Laughter]
all right so then okay great that's a
good title so this is so next week on
friday you guys understand we did kim
pete and kanye on monday changed the
title today we went live did kim pete
kanye it's gonna change your title today
to make a title before we go live and
say no it's just a lot you look at the
topics and we just people are tuning in
it's fine you know but on friday we're
gonna have the same [ __ ] title
compete god damn maybe it'll stick on
friday maybe yeah we'll put it at the
top of the show doc although we have we
do have a pretty fire calling lined up
for friday
the um
the
how do i say this without giving away
who it is well it's so obscure nobody
will even know we found a guy on tick
tock that [ __ ] peanut butter and he's
calling oh okay
yeah that's fun that's great that's
really exciting that's exciting dude
allegedly
well he that's what's interesting he's
very ambiguous about it but there's all
gets to the bottom
yeah that's why we wanted you to talk to
him because we knew ethan would be this
is a fresh air exclusive yeah i'm gonna
get to the bottom of this
he posted one where the jar is looks
like a um
something um
phallic if you will was stuck
in the jar was it was it what was the
phallic size was he like stacked oh this
he's girthy dude
what were you getting so i just wanted
to because people in the chat are asking
about lina lina is okay thank you all
for asking uh for those who don't know
she had a lump on her neck we were
scared but it ended up being nothing so
yay
we got benign we got so so you guys went
to the doctor they touched the lump they
looked at it what'd they say
i said she's fine i didn't go with her
um
which makes me sound really bad now that
i say it out loud but
we were recording but uh no she said
they said that she was fine i don't know
what exactly how it went down lean are
you there
lena come
talk about the lump talk about the lump
talk about the love so he just felt it
and he said it was fine he compared it
to the opposite side and he said i had
perfect symmetry and nothing to worry
about
wait so there wasn't even a lump there
there was but he said that
what he was feeling that it was fine
it's not something to be concerned about
and then like he just checked like
compared it to the other side to be just
to be sure so you have two lumps no no
our lovely lady humps just um
yeah i'm very happy to hear that thank
you yes what happened to ela
we were i was so scared when you let
that you know i was freaking out i was
like bro i would stay up at night be
like oh my god bro my life is over he
was definitely gonna die of like these
[ __ ] like
elaborate
fantasies about ela's gonna die i'm at
her funeral what am i going to do
how am i going to go on just like all
playing out my head and then you go to
the doctor he's like she's fine you're
like okay cool
yeah no it's scary but
i'm doula everything's
[Applause]
um
i honestly forget
the word for what
like god bless well there's an
expression that's similar to
alhamdulillah like uh you know
thank god or whatever god's name
whatever
all right
that's good enough
well that was a fun paulie where are you
wally reach out thanks everyone for
tuning in we got good numbers today
you think it's the title or doing
numbers boy no i think do you think it's
just a good episode or do you think it's
the good episode
we're just cruising
i mean this is no this is average for
the last couple weeks we've been always
hitting around 47 000 is is kai
really go back and look okay yeah well
thank you super troopers on monday we
hit 50 or like just below 50 or
something so yeah yeah you're right
actually yeah that's awesome that's
great that's why i'm saying the sub
thing is really good our numbers are
that's why i don't care about the
subject exactly
the show is doing great i just don't i
don't know
that we've like grown the past couple
weeks and it was a couple weeks ago we
started shouting the sub count out so in
my opinion the subs are down
yeah but
i hear what you're saying but
no no no no no no live view the people
who know this is how dangerous you can
remove this people said please let me
pull it up on my phone okay this is cool
no this is the actual i'm in the back
end and i want to do a live view let me
match it up on my phone okay uh also
another quick update yeah exactly
hopefully on friday we will have all the
details of the idubbbz fight that i'm
gonna be in oh
finally get to announce
you're gonna [ __ ] that guy up dude
a little bit you feeling calm don't say
it you almost said it exactly
i said a little [ __ ] boy
we'll save it for friday you cut
yourself away
b's opponent or a b
maybe he's a owner it hasn't been
announced and zach is talking [ __ ] about
him around the office all the time and
he's totally he has a more you call him
little [ __ ] boy well he calls him just
just just
yeah yeah zack's gonna fight it before
you can get to him yeah i believe it i
don't know anything about him he's going
down guys for we're hammering wait it
went significantly that's why i said get
it off screen i don't care i don't care
i mean that is actually the show is
doing good who cares
people are watching we have almost 50
000 people watching us that's awesome
everybody will watch right
thank you thank you this is a serious
message
i think we'll get more subs when we
start interviewing people again
that's when you get subscribers on
podcast and by the way
we're trying to book interesting guests
and uh
nobody wants to be on our show
i know what to say
that's not really that's not true
coconuts and barbados won't come on
they'll come on
they keep saying that
they were in the middle they had their
chance they had roller tony they had the
whole thing
maybe if you guys have some guest
suggestions
[Music]
you know you gotta give me some more
that's right
are they still live shout out tim
heidecker shout out rolo toner shout out
tony let's see shout out
tony working
all right well they missed their chance
they're like dude nobody wants to nobody
wants to see us debate h3 they want to
hear rollo tony talk about the how women
how many sex women have had
how many partners women have had how it
really does matter mr martial
is so scary dude it's so [ __ ] scary
i want to read it but every time i go
there it just
i can imagine though i mean if you
actually listen to that stuff you must
be really [ __ ] in the head
like all i feel like anyone who watches
fresh and fits seriously mom made them
the uh mangina
yeah
yep
you know
me and now
you know what i'm saying all right
enough of that
guys let us know if you have suggestions
i want to get some some guests out here
bobby lee yeah we should get bobby lee
out actually maybe you want to invite
him on dan you can email the producers
love bobby
anyone else
tim dillon maybe
yeah are you i'm in touch with tim i can
invite him on casey neistat
it's actually good to talk about the
david yeah
well that's a really good idea i'll text
i'll text casey
um
anything else since we're brainstorming
here
when is drew coming on ro
rewind
this video about 10 minutes we just went
we just went
she had a scheduling conflict so we got
to reschedule
the thing is i'm
not nothing against youtubers i just
feel like we've talked to so many
youtubers
it's basically the best i want to talk
to like
you know
other people producers of reality shows
that you're into well he said no to us i
know but though andy cohen's a big deal
that's the most i'm just saying that's
the most excited i've seen you forget
about a guest in a long time yeah he he
he knowed us yeah
he said he's not doing media at this
time
so watch him like a [ __ ] hawk because
if he goes on another show yeah the
minute i see you on someone's show dude
andy
chloe cherry have we tried to reach out
to chloe cherry
what come on get on it
i know now i'm home now i will do it
well well you're at school what are you
guys doing
she said she wanted to do it but we've
i've been asking you guys to reach out
to her for like weeks
i don't know what to say
chloe cherry if you're watching come on
let's talk about how you reach out
we beat that all right to be fair olivia
said you i'm not trying to throw you
under the bus but you did say you would
do that yes you know what i found info i
don't have login info for reaching out
to her
okay let's start okay sorry sorry let's
not assign blame busting
but uh
olivia's at school
okay
thank you can you interview david lynch
i would love to i don't i don't know if
the weather today
fifty
seventy-five degrees
it's a friday once again
yeah i like maybe you watch a movie on
your [ __ ] iphone
get [ __ ] real
great a lot of these people we've
reached out to like i see people saying
rock bretman rock we've tried
mac demarco i can try again
ring a star that'd be awesome oh my god
that would be amazing bingo starring
he's in l.a that would be game-changing
dude
oh my god
uh that was very charming in interviews
too oh so many suggestions if we could
actually get them on which i doubt let's
reach out let's try just say we're huge
fans peace and love
he hates the peace and love [ __ ] so
don't maybe don't
i mean he still says it all the time but
no he doesn't like the that it's like a
meme the specific clip that is memed
right of him being angry at fans he
doesn't like
i think we've reached out she's like so
big time
it's pretty good but i mean our podcast
is pretty popular so i don't understand
why
we can't guess guests like that i guess
i don't know if we need to hire a booker
or
we've hired bookers in the past
[ __ ] it's just [ __ ] they don't do
[ __ ] [ __ ] they really don't and
they're so expensive yeah
okay but we'll we'll start working
towards it jenna marbles i tried i
invite dude listen to this i i messaged
i know jenna marbles is off
um twitter
so what happened
i
think i messaged
i messaged julian and say hey would
jenna want to come on
and then like he closed his instagram
the next day
[Laughter]
that would be fun i'd like to talk to
her we tried i love britney that's what
i'm saying why does anyone want to come
on like we have a popular show
like yeah i don't understand the podcast
instagram is
they dm'd her and then
ghosts
ghosted
a big deal
in the world
joji i mean
that might be my dream guest if i'm
gonna be honest he's not coming on no i
know
george like he's embarrassed by his
youtube career so like he's yeah he's
like
doesn't want to associate with anyone or
anything that reminds people of filthy
frank
what about another uh can't say i blame
him
jack and eric episode
oh jack and eric sure that'd be that
would be awesome dude
the boys
[ __ ] mack yeah
that's true let's get [ __ ] jack and
eric back in here yeah we could do that
paulie's sure
polly we could get easy
well yeah he was in our chat
um
all right enough guys thanks for
watching friday's gonna be off the rails
the title of friday's episode kim pete
and kanye
you don't want to miss it
have a good week
friday we'll be back
yadda yadda this is ethan clyde from
clean air today in ukraine
people are getting absolutely [ __ ] up
in other news
i'm hungry
food
the weather outside is 75 degrees
and i need to take a piss
this is ethan cly
[Music]
for npr
[Music]
saying see you on friday
[Music]
you